Guys, I'm a little bit of a mess right now.
I don't know a way to open up a stream.
Guys, I'm waiting for my food right now.
I'm so hungry.
Hello everybody!
Hello!
Anyway, so for those of you who didn't read on the pinned message...
I ordered lasagna today because I was like...
You know what?
I'm going to treat myself.
Because I had...
Because dad here...
Somebody's moving in again.
Moving in today.
So he woke me up like three times.
He woke me up three times.
And then I found out today...
I found out...
I was like... I had a package.
I didn't realize I ordered something.
And then I found out that the package...
arrived at my old place.
So then I called.
And I was like...
Hey, I used to live here.
This is my name and this is my...
The unit I used to live in.
And like...
Do you have a package for me?
And then they're like...
Let me check.
And they're like...
No!
I'm like...
Oh, okay.
So I was like...
Time to order lasagna and eat my feelings.
I was like... You know what?
That's too much to start the day.
I'm going to...
I'm going to order lasagna.
That's too much.
So, yes.
Today I'm getting lasagna.
I'm not going to eat my bread supply.
Which I put the bread in the freezer, guys.
So, like, I still have a lot of bread.
And I...
I bought too much bread, guys.
I'm already so over it.
I was like...
Wait.
Even though bread...
Like, you know, even though it was like, you know...
Nice bread.
Like...
They sort of taste the same.
I was like...
Wow, all this bread...
Just tastes like all the other bread.
It's just bread.
I was like...
Yeah, there's different flavor bread.
But, like, deep down, it's just...
The bread taste.
And I was like...
Why did I buy two bags of bread?
I guess I just haven't had...
I just haven't had, like, freshly baked bread in a long time.
So...
So, like, I don't know what came over me.
I don't...
Oh, my God.
They all look so good, but they all sort of taste the same.
It's just...
It doesn't matter.
Yeah.
Anyway, so...
It's gonna arrive in, like, 10 minutes.
Okay, let me double check.
I'm gonna stop moving for a little bit.
Um...
Let me double check real...
Oh, yeah, sorry.
I'm loading in.
I wanna make sure it is coming at 1245.
If it is...
Okay, yes, it's still 1245.
Alright, at 1245, I'm out.
Anyway, today...
Today, I walked dad today.
And...
Um...
Oh, my God, every day he reminds me of how much he's such a little shit.
Like...
So...
So, today...
Today, while I was walking him...
We bumped into this, like...
We were, like, waiting to cross the street.
And then...
You guys all know...
He only likes women.
He hates men.
He does not like men.
Of any height.
So, it doesn't...
And children, too.
So, he's traumatized, like, one or two kids since I moved here.
Because, like...
I couldn't get him...
Like, you know, the child would, like, walk past me during the lobby.
And then he'll be like...
Like, he'll be like, tiny dog.
So...
So, he hates... No, he does.
He hates the kids and the elderly.
And...
So, whenever I see a child, I, like, make sure...
Like, we walk a different direction.
So, he doesn't see the child.
Or, like, he doesn't get close to the child.
Because I didn't want to traumatize kids, you know?
Because I'm like...
We live in the same building.
And I'm worried that, like, I'm gonna bump into you again.
And then you're gonna blame me...
For giving your kids trauma...
And therapy lessons.
Because they can't handle dogs anymore.
Because I don't want that to be on me.
And I'm worried there.
So...
No, sometimes I pick him up.
And sometimes I just make sure...
He doesn't get close to the children.
So, he's only traumatized...
One or two child now.
One of them cried.
I was... I felt so bad.
I was like...
I am so sorry.
I'm so sorry.
So...
One cried.
One didn't.
So, like, I count that as a win.
In terms of, like, I didn't traumatize that many children.
Like, since moving here.
So...
I'm worried for you too.
Because it's my birthday!
Sorry!
Thank you!
Happy birthday to you!
Yeah!
Happy birthday dear SoulOrd!
Happy birthday to you!
Yeah!
So...
Basically...
We had that issue.
We're working on that issue.
We're working on it.
Anyway...
Other than that...
So...
He also hates men, children, and the elderly.
But he loves women.
So...
He loves ladies.
So basically...
While I was taking him for a walk today...
This morning...
There was a couple in front of me while waiting to cross the street with me.
And then...
He was very interested in the lady.
And so he was, like, sniffing her leg.
And was like...
Yeah!
Lady!
And then the guy noticed it.
And he was the one that was like...
Oh, dog!
And he was like...
What a cute dog!
Like, the lady didn't acknowledge him.
But the guy did.
So that the guy was like...
Hello there!
And then he stick out his hand.
And was like...
And then Doki Amber Doge walked up.
Sniffed his hand.
I thought it was a good encounter.
I thought he was going to be okay.
Because he didn't seem like too...
He didn't seem aggressive.
And then he, like, sniffed his hand.
And was like...
He tried to nip his hand.
And, like, a warning nip.
And then started barking at him.
I was like...
You sniffed his hand!
He didn't bite anybody.
He was, like, pretend bite.
You know?
Like he was posturing.
He was like...
And then he started barking at him.
And he was like...
Whoa!
And I was like...
Are you serious?
I was like...
Dad, no!
And I'm like... I'm sorry!
I'm so sorry!
And he's like... No, it's okay.
Because I was like... Why did you approach him?
And you don't like him!
I'm just...
You're not a lady...
He's like... He sniffs the hand.
And you're like... You're no lady!
Get out!
He's just like...
Lady hands only!
Because if it's a woman...
He wouldn't do that.
Like, you know...
I'd go on the walks and then like...
A lady would come up and be like...
Aww, cute dog!
And then he would be like...
Yay!
Yay, pet me!
Oh my god!
Give me love and attention!
But if it's a man...
He would not!
He could smell the testosterone.
If it's a man...
Then back off!
But then he always gives them like...
A false sense of security.
That's like the worst part.
He pretends that he's okay.
And then he lets them get close to him.
And like...
He would sniff the hand.
And then when he smells them...
He's like... No!
He's like...
Wait a minute.
You're no lady.
Why did I let you approach me?
Anyway...
But yes, that is how...
This is... God damn it.
I don't know where he gets this from.
I don't know where he...
I don't know why he hates men!
And children!
And the elderly!
I don't know why!
He just likes women!
He doesn't care about anything else!
Anyway...
That's basically...
Life update today.
That's my...
That's my life update for the day.
Um...
Oh yeah, by the way, have you guys seen the eSports GeoGuessr World Cup?
I heard about that going on in the background.
But like...
I didn't watch the stream of it.
Yeah, they had a GeoGuessr World Cup.
It was like eSports.
Wait, some of you guys didn't see it?
It was crazy!
I watched the...
I watched the VOD of it and they were like...
They were commentating on it as if it's like a real...
It's so intense.
Like the eSport of GeoGuessr.
Holy shit!
Like they actually had like...
Sportscasters and stuff.
Like eSportcasters doing it.
It was so fucking crazy!
You guys have to...
I'll show you guys the...
You guys have to watch the...
Like people!
Like the...
The sportscasting for it was insane.
I'm just gonna show you.
Yeah, it was...
It literally happened like...
Two days ago.
The finals.
But it was actually insane.
Like how crazy it was.
Yeah, like I was like...
I guess I heard about it, but I didn't watch it.
Okay, let me...
My food might be here.
Oh shit!
Okay, it's here!
I'll be right back!
I'm back.
I'm back with my lasagna.
Okay, give me a sec.
Let me...
I'm sorry guys.
This is just...
This ends up being like a...
Fucking...
This is eating...
Eating stream.
Give me a sec.
Please let me eat.
Okay.
There we go.
Oh my god.
Lasagna!
Yay!
Got my lasagna!
Let's go!
Oh my god.
I'm so happy.
Oh, I knew they wouldn't fucking give me a fork.
Even though I requested utensils.
I don't understand!
I just wanted a fork!
Yay!
Oh my god, it's so hot!
This has to be fresh lasagna!
This better be fucking fresh lasagna!
I waited like... Oh, they did give me a fork.
It's a wooden fork.
I fucking... Okay.
Save the environment.
But fuck, I hate the wooden forks.
God damn it.
This better be fresh lasagna.
This took an hour.
This took an hour to get here.
This better be fresh as fuck.
Literally, the restaurant was dedicated to just lasagna.
God, it has to be a ghost kitchen.
Oh my god.
Now that I think about it.
Why was it just lasagna?
That doesn't seem very like...
This better be like...
This better not be a ghost kitchen.
Okay.
Yogi has the most real voice I've ever heard in a...
I've ever heard in a VTuber because this is my real voice.
I can't...
I can't fake a voice.
It would fuck with me.
No!
And also the jalapeno pepper poppers too.
No food.
You can't have human food.
Okay?
Oh my god, it looks so good.
Oh my god, I haven't had lasagna in so long.
Oh my gosh.
I'm going to be just like my hero.
Oh my god, I'm going to be just like my hero.
I haven't had lasagna in so long.
God, please be good.
Please be good.
I waited an hour for this.
You know mukbang?
The reason why mukbang is so popular is because it actually makes it so that you're not as hungry when you watch and listen to other people eat.
I don't know if it actually works if like, you know, you don't see the food in front of you.
You don't see the food in front of you.
People like used to watch mukbang because it's like it helps deter hunger or something.
So I don't know if that's like I don't know if that's like actually a thing because I don't I personally I'm always two steps ahead.
That shit was great.
That's so...
That is psychopathic behavior.
I'm sorry.
Like if you guys didn't know what's his name?
Nico Avocado or whatever.
That shit is psychopathic.
Like I'm sorry.
Like that's crazy.
The Avocadoman.
So for those who don't know, there was this guy that was famous for making drama and like causing drama like almost every week.
And he was extremely, extremely overweight to the point where like people were actually concerned about his health.
And then, but what apparently what happened was that he was, he pre-recorded videos for two, like he pre-recorded two years worth of videos on three different channels.
And then just spent the whole time just losing weight.
And losing weight in every thing.
And I was, and like but like I'm just like, that's that's fucking crazy.
Like I was like why?
For two years, like two years.
He has three different channels by the way, which he updated regularly.
Like I mean, people would be like, wow that's like fucking crazy.
Like that, that like he actually that was like good, I guess like content wise.
That's pretty fucking crazy.
But it is crazy.
That shit is crazy.
Imagine if all these videos, all these streams were pre-recorded.
Like two years worth and I just come back.
Two steps ahead.
Like I come back as a new person.
All these streams and all these videos you saw.
And like and then the fact that like he was able to make sure that zero dates were anywhere.
Like I assume he like changed the dates on his phones too.
And everything to make it work.
It's just crazy.
Yeah, like I don't know what like like I don't know.
It's just I don't know.
Like couldn't he just IMO?
I'm just like couldn't he just you know like document himself losing weight?
I feel like people would enjoy that more cause you're like being healthier on like
Not the whole like gotcha.
The gotcha moment and everything.
This is a really good lasagna by the way.
I'm trying to make sure he doesn't fucking.
I'm trying.
I'm ignoring him cause if I give him what he wants then he'll know that if he barks he'll get food and I don't want that.
So I'm trying to teach him a lesson.
That he can't Barking does not solve everything.
The barking is pre-recorded.
I don't think mukbangs.
Oh by the way I don't think mukbangs are popular anymore.
I don't know if people actually still watch mukbangs.
Those were like a 2010 trend.
I feel like I don't even know what newest like internet trend now.
Hmm Oh yeah did you guys see the minecraft?
I know I like I'm like late to the party.
I saw the minecraft trailer when it came out.
That shit looked like ass.
But Like I don't know what to say other than like it's crazy that Jack Black has now in just two movies and just like within like two to three months Jack Black's reputation has tanked so much.
Um In like in like three to four months it literally tanked so hard like it's actually he fell off so hard I don't
In two to three months it's like it's actually so sad it's so sad like everybody loved him and then two to three months it just bad news keep coming over and over and over.
Wait wait wait wait wait wait wait hmm If I'm Mario that's last year I cannot wait to watch Borderlands with you guys though cannot wait
it's because like people are casting him as Jack Black let's say Chris Pratt first so instead of him playing character cause at least in Mario he played Bowser you know he played Okay, Bowser, but Kung Fu Panda 4... okay.
Guys, no, you do not...
Kung Fu Panda 4 is not a good representation.
If anything, it just backs up my claim.
All I'm saying is that...
they're now doing a thing with Chris Pratt...
and Awkwafina.
God, I hate Awkwafina.
I used to like her...
until every time they casted her...
she's just playing herself.
I used to like her stuff.
But then, literally...
I hate that...
every time they get Awkwafina...
they just make her play Awkwafina.
Like, I'm just like...
please.
She's a good actress.
She's actually a really good actress.
I actually went to a theater to watch the one...
that movie where she...
that one that got nominated for an Oscar...
about her going back to...
going back to Asia to visit her grandma...
who was dying...
who got like...
who got cancer.
And like...
The Farewell.
Yes, The Farewell.
That movie was so good.
I actually watched it.
I really liked The Farewell.
And it's such a good movie.
But like...
and then...
but they keep casting her as like...
herself.
And it's like...
I'm just sad.
Cause like...
Awkwafina...
I feel like she's a really good actress.
But...
she's just...
get casted and like...
as herself.
Which is like Chris Pratt.
I fucking hate the Chris Pratt syndrome.
Where they just cast actors and actresses...
as themselves.
And I'm tired of that.
Yeah, she gets typecasted.
And like...
that's what's happening to Jack Black right now.
He's literally getting casted as himself.
Like how is that Steve?
It's literally just Jack Black with a blue shirt.
And it's like two blue shirts?
I...
I don't understand the costume.
It's like a V-neck...
sweater.
And then underneath is another shirt.
Like...
I don't understand.
why is he wearing two shirts?
Why?
Why is he wearing two shirts?
Like...
it's a V-neck, but like...
there's a shirt underneath the V-neck?
Like...
Somebody made a...
Lego parody...
of the trailer...
and it looked really good.
I...
I wish like...
um...
I wish that like...
the main character...
The Minecraft movie was like blocky like the Lego movie, but not like Minecraft animation, because I personally think like the Minecraft and I know there's someone made like a Minecraft parody of it, like Minecraft animation, but like, I think the Lego one looked so much better.
Um, yeah.
And then like, Pharoah Williams is making a Lego movie of his own fucking life, which I thought looked really interesting.
I don't know if you guys saw the trailer for it.
But, you know, Pharoah Williams, the one that made all the Despicable Me songs, like, that's the question and happy.
Yeah, he's making like a biopic pic, but he's making it all in Lego.
Like he's doing like, Lego animation for it.
Yeah, it looked really cool.
And then he has like all these like big famous rappers, like an actual interviews, but like, they're like Lego.
So like, there's like, like Snoop Dogg, 50 Cent, like, they're all like Lego.
So funny.
This is so funny.
I saw, I saw the trailer for it looked really interesting.
Like all these famous rappers.
Just doing it.
Like they don't didn't know they were gonna be in Lego too.
So it's really silly.
Hmm.
This is a really good lasagna.
God, it's gonna be so sad.
If it was like because it was like, It was like literally a restaurant that just sold lasagna, so I was like, oh no, did I order from a ghost kitchen?
But like even if this is a ghost kitchen, this is pretty decent lasagna for a ghost kitchen.
Lego Loki becoming like Disney, that is such a huge insult to Lego.
We don't want anything to become like Disney.
Did you hear that Pixar?
What was it?
Inside Out 2 became the number one animated movie, top grossing animated movie, which I was very surprised.
I watched Inside Out 2.
It was not that good.
Like I was good, but like not that good.
It was good, but not that good.
Also like number two was fucking The Lion King, the live action movie, which was not live action, but like the live action slash animated movie was Lion King.
That's number two.
I was like, what?
I was so surprised.
Inflation, yeah.
They don't take into account of inflation.
So that's why it was like number two.
But like, oh my god, like Inside Out 2 is just Inside Out 1.
But they introduced like it's literally the same movie.
It's the same movie.
It's like it's the same plot and everything.
It's the same plot.
It's literally the same plot.
Like anxiety, it was joy in Inside Out 1.
They didn't learn anything from the first movie.
And then, but the thing is, like Inside Out 2 became the highest grossing animated movie of all time.
But then, Pixar fired like a lot of their staff during the production of Inside Out 2.
That's fucked.
And they didn't get health insurance.
I was like, what the fucked?!
I read that, I was like, that's so fucked!
Inside Out 2 became the highest grossing animated movie.
And like a portion of the staff that worked on that movie got fired.
And it didn't even get health insurance or like, what is it, like the package that you get from the people.
If you get fired, you get like a package or whatever.
Sorry, I don't have a real job.
I'm sorry.
Severance package, yeah.
They didn't get a severance right after they got fired.
So people were like, how the fuck did Inside Out 2 become the highest-grossing anime movie?
And some of the staff that worked on it didn't even get severance pay.
Like, they made so much money off of that.
Welcome to Corpa.
I know.
Yeah.
Apparently, like, Disney working condition has not been great lately.
Well, it's been not great for a couple of fucking years.
I'm not surprised.
That's so wrong.
It's so wrong.
It is.
It's actually so messed up.
But it's also, like, the industry, too.
Tech industry got overloaded because of COVID.
So a lot of companies that use technology, especially game development and, like, game development, animation, all that.
A lot of them overhired.
And after COVID was over, like, so many people got fired.
It's so fucked, I feel like.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah, there's been so many layoffs.
I heard, like, especially in game development, too.
Because people, like, overhired so much for anything with regarding tech.
Yeah.
Society.
I mean, Microsoft shut down game companies for no reason.
Like...
Like, nobody knows why they shut down the companies.
They shut down the company for Hi-Fi Rush.
They never gave, like, a reason for it.
They were just, like, we're shutting them down.
Like, I don't know.
I was like, what?
They made money.
They're just, like, anyway, we're shutting down the company that, like, you know, they won some awards or whatever.
But we're gonna shut them down.
I get it.
And then...
Thank God.
Thank God PUBG bought them, though.
PUBG...
At least PUBG bought the rights.
So, they're now owned by PUBG.
Which I thought was pretty funny, too.
That Hi-Fi Rush is now owned by PUBG.
Tax write-off bullshit should not be a thing.
This is why we don't get the Wile E.
Coyote movie.
It shouldn't be a thing.
I'm thinking... I feel like...
There's no reason to be...
Like...
What are you gonna do with being...
Oh, boo-hoo.
I'm gonna be less of a millionaire now.
And I'm like, you're not even...
You're gonna, like...
Live all that money?
Die.
And you're still not...
You're still gonna be a millionaire.
It doesn't matter.
Like, this is me.
But, like...
Um...
I feel like...
I don't understand, like...
Like...
Millionaires slash billionaires.
Cause, like...
They're all about profit, right?
Like, profit, profit, profit.
But, like...
You live your whole life...
You live your whole life off that money.
And, like...
When you die...
You're still gonna be a millionaire.
Like...
Like, you're still gonna be a millionaire.
You're not gonna be able to...
Spend all that money.
Like...
For my children!
Your kids!
Are gonna be able to spend all that money.
And still gonna be okay.
Like...
They're gonna...
Live off that money.
Die.
And they're still gonna be okay.
Like...
I was like...
And still...
They're still gonna be a millionaire.
So, I never understand, like...
The whole, like...
Profit...
Like...
Extreme profit thing.
Um...
What kids...
What...
Oh, sorry.
They need to pay off their...
Like...
Seventh divorce or some shit.
Bro wants to be on the leaderboards.
You understand, Toki?
Bro needs to be on the top ten leaderboards of billionaires.
Like...
That's why I don't understand.
That's why I don't understand, like...
The...
Um...
How...
Why, like...
Why...
Um...
Certain companies go, like...
Do that.
For, like...
Tax write-offs and shit like that.
Like...
Getting rid of perfectly good, like...
Video games.
Or...
Com...
Like...
Perfectly...
Okay...
Games and companies.
And, like...
Um...
Movies or whatever.
And they're like...
We gotta...
We gotta have, like...
More profit.
But I'm like...
You guys are fine.
You guys...
Like...
Grinding for top 50 in the game of the line.
Bro...
You don't understand.
You're so close to top 500 in NA, guys.
Yeah...
For me, it's like...
As long...
As, like...
I'm 50...
And I have, like...
A nice place to retire.
Like...
I don't have to care.
I don't have to worry about my health or stuff.
That's all I care about.
Like...
This is my job.
I'm already...
Like...
Living the best I can live.
I'm...
I'm literally...
Eating lasagna.
And I just made $10.
Thank you so much.
Giga...
Thank you...
Super chat...
Super...
Free...
I'm eating...
Lasagna...
And I just got $10.
Thank you so much.
Okay.
I'll put my lasagna away now.
We're actually...
It's been 40...
I'm so sorry for those who are waiting for wukana.
I'm...
I'm so sorry...
For those waiting for wukana.
Let me put away my lasagna.
Let me put this away.
Oh...
Alright, let's see.
I'm sorry for those who don't like ASMR and have to listen to me munch on lasagna.
I'm sorry, but I'm done now.
WUKAN!
Lasagna was pretty good!
I liked it.
I like the lasagna.
I haven't had any for a while.
And like...
I wanted to treat myself today.
So I was like, you know what?
Fuck it.
Let's go.
Alright.
I don't remember how to play this game.
So this is gonna be interesting to get back into.
I remember...
Apparently, I'm in the spider village and...
I defeated the yellow dragon.
I don't remember how the controls work anymore.
I think I'm like literally the 1% that uses mouse and keyboard controls.
I like the mouse and keyboard controls.
More than...
I personally like it more than...
More than controller.
Oh yeah, I was here!
Why was I here?
What was I doing here?
Is there upgrades?
Oh yeah, I do!
Nice, okay.
Alright, increased gourd usage.
Yeah, we're increasing our gourd usage.
Alright, store.
What's there to buy?
Wine worm.
Oh, it's just for upgrades.
Okay.
We don't need that.
We're fine.
We're okay.
Okay.
Uh...
Does he have an update for me?
Hello?
Okay, he has no updates.
Oh, nice!
More stuff that I wasn't gonna use.
Nice.
More stuff I'm not gonna use in the end.
Guys, you don't understand.
I'm saving it up for Wukong 2.
What if the...
What if the items, like, pass over to Wukong 2?
Guys, Wukong harder.
You guys don't know that?
It could, like...
It could, like, transfer over.
What if I need it?
Uh...
Wait, I can challenge him?
Okay.
Can I challenge him again?
Do I get more stuff if I challenge him again?
Chat?
Or is it just a one-time thing?
No?
Why the fuck would I want to fight you?
Okay, let's see.
Yes.
Not now.
Okay.
I'm not...
No.
I didn't...
Acted like a monkey.
Millionaire!
Kaz!
Thank you!
Super chat!
No, you don't understand!
No!
I gotta make sure I'm okay in second life!
Oh, no.
Did I fuck it up?
Okay, whoops.
Alright.
Sorry.
I just...
I like to run.
I...
Where am I going?
I'll never know where am I going!
Wait, wait, wait.
Okay.
We can leave now.
Alright.
We are...
Should we...
We should be at...
Oh my god.
I'm like...
I'm so like...
I don't know where we've been.
We're leaving...
Oh, there we go!
We were here.
He just loves to run, chat.
He just loves to run.
I think like everybody like finished this game and I'm still like on chapter four.
Am I chapter four?
Yeah.
There's still two more chapters.
Two...
I'm gonna try and finish...
The reason why I streamed this early today is I'm gonna try and finish another chapter.
Okay.
I'm gonna try and finish another chapter today.
Like I'm at part seven.
We're still...
We're still here.
Is there anything I'm missing here though?
Alright.
How do I fight?
Okay.
That's how I fight.
And then...
Okay.
There's that.
And there's my different stances.
Okay.
Wait.
How do I...
Okay.
There you go.
My talisman.
Alright.
Let's go.
Okay.
Off we go.
Things can't be that bad now.
Right?
Okay.
Watch this.
I remember how to fight.
See?
God.
I'm so fucking weak.
I remember how fucking weak I am.
Okay.
Oh.
Why are these so tanky?
See.
I told you.
I can...
I still remember.
I still remember how to play.
Oh my god.
Street Fighter made my fucking reflexes even better.
Look at that.
Oh.
Oh my god.
I'll say my reflexes are even better now.
I still got it.
I still got it, chat.
Oh shit.
Okay.
What's this move?
What is...
Oh.
Hello.
I didn't...
I was...
I didn't know.
I...
I was like...
I died.
I had to figure out what that move was.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Reload.
Now I know.
He never saw it coming.
Is that...
That's a...
That's a scorpion, guys.
That's not a cockroach.
That's a...
Guys.
He has a tail.
He has a...
Okay.
Nice.
Oh.
I got leaves.
Gold leaves.
Okay.
I mean.
What's so funny?
It's not so bad.
Okay.
Then grab.
All right.
Let's see...
Where do I have to go?
Oh my god.
Does it...
Do I get less loss...?
Like...
Will there be any point of time where I get less loss?
Like, in this game?
I'm poisoned.
Don't worry.
I can...
All...
Like...
Like every time you get poisoned you'll eventually get un-poisoned.
What?
Who the fuck shot me?
I was scared.
I was checking sightseeing.
Oh no.
Oh no, there's so many.
Where the fuck did you come from?
Yes, higher.
Oh no.
There's so many pathways.
I forgot how...
how many pathways there are in this world.
Okay, I haven't got this yet.
Alright.
That's my secret.
I'm always lost.
That way.
Okay.
Do I go down?
Can I go down?
Oh, I can.
What is it with...
You know what?
I see green thing here.
I absorb.
I feel like going down is like...
It's like the last thing I should be doing though.
Oh no.
Okay, apparently I can't go back up.
Okay.
I guess we go down.
I can't.
Where am I?
I don't...
I can't believe how many bugs are in this chapter.
Shaking my head.
I was thinking it was a super chat.
Where am I?
Actually, where am I?
Oh my god, I can't believe I didn't dodge that.
I made it down from here.
That's right, anti-air.
Where is this place?
Where?
Okay, let's go.
Here we go.
Down we go.
So we're trying to find our friend.
Pigsy.
Chupacay.
We're trying to find him because like...
I don't know.
He fucked a spider.
I feel like he always has like a spider like girlfriend.
Oh, this is it.
I somehow went the right way.
I don't know how.
No, Pigsy.
I know she has many legs, but it's not worth it.
Chupacay, it's not worth it.
Those legs.
Big day.
Shut up.
You know what they say about eight legs.
Big day.
There's a word for you.
I'm the big day.
I'm the biggest day.
Oh, that's cool.
If I ever see you again...
I'm going to get it.
If I ever see you again, I'm going to get it.
I understand why...
It's because I have a big day.
I wouldn't be in this situation.
If I were you, I wouldn't be in this situation.
Okay.
Make her happy.
Make me happy.
There are children!
There are so many children!
It's not all about looks, ladies.
Oh my god, so conceited.
No, we still don't have figure subtitles.
They did nerf some characters though.
Some bosses.
After I killed them.
So like, that's cool.
They nerfed two bosses, which I beat before.
So I beat the hard version of them.
And then they nerfed them afterwards.
So like, fuck me, I guess.
Is this like the baby sister?
Is that a baby sister she's holding on to?
The translation is different from what they're saying.
You know when they're like, wait!
But then she actually was like, sister!
The subtitles are translating the English dialogue.
It's just little things.
It's cause she's getting old.
Put her in a home, I guess.
Look, she's getting old.
She needs to settle.
If it has to be a pig man, then welcome your new stepfather.
Mother is usually good.
Only when she's eating, she's the only one who thinks alone.
Don't get her into trouble.
Mother is usually good.
Only when she's eating, she's the only one who thinks alone.
Let her settle!
She needs somebody to take care!
And don't let her die alone!
Like, I can't believe they're judging her pig.
Like, I mean, he seems like a respectable pig.
Oh, she's old old.
Yeah, he's like one of the top pig bachelors.
Yay!
See?
Even spider grannies can find love.
Guys.
See?
No matter what, even the spider grannies can find love in the end.
Where am I?
Okay, so this way... Alright, so I'm gonna teleport back and go the other way.
I'll go back for you later.
I realize I can explore a different way.
Even if her daughter... Don't worry, I just realized there's another way I should go then.
Sorry.
Sorry, Pigsy.
Sorry, Chewbacca.
I need a...
I need... I need...
I need to go the other way.
I need to explore.
Okay, so this way is to...
This way will be to the spider lady.
So I can go this way.
That means I can go this way, guys.
And that should give me another pathway.
Because the other way is to the plot.
And we don't need to go to do the plot yet.
We can explore.
Don't worry, I'll be back for you!
Don't worry!
Go have some granny action!
You know, I'm giving them this... I'm giving him some time.
I'm giving him like privacy, you know?
I'm a good friend.
I'm literally such a good friend.
I'm letting him have a good time.
Oh, I should... Maybe I'll just grab this.
Go!
Oh, my monkeys!
There's a spirit there.
Go do your thing.
What the fuck?
Okay, I guess we all are gonna get trapped.
Not like that, though.
Not like that.
All right.
Oh, shit!
Summons time.
Okay, I never used the summons before.
Okay, heavy attack.
Okay, do I do damage?
Like, oh my god, it's like...
What!
That's it!
Wait, is that actually it?
Oh, God, I'm him.
There's no way!
That's actually it!
I mean, okay.
I guess it's because he's like...
Oh, but it's like a lot- Oh!
wait, never mind, never mind!
Okay, that's a lot of damage!
Never mind, I didn't realize this fucking thing lasts forever.
Actually, it is worth it.
Holy shit this This thing lasts forever.
Like, that fucking summon lasts so long.
I need to build focus.
Oh, his counter is very powerful.
He stopped, he let himself go.
He's let himself go afterwards.
Okay, nice.
Don't worry, Chewbacca, I'll come back for you, I swear to god.
I'm sorry, like, all I'm saying is that, like, I don't know, like...
Come on, you have a hot grand grand situation going on.
And I'm just trying to make sure I'm... I can retire.
Okay, let's see.
Okay, we got a summon.
I guess we can go downstairs.
Hello.
Alright.
Is there anything here?
What's over here?
Ooh.
What is over here?
Where am I?
Where the fuck am I?
I'm fucking...
Where the fuck is this place?
Okay,
let's see.
Yeah, I'm just being a good bro.
I'm just being a good bro.
I'm just being a good bro, guys.
Wait, is this the...
God damn it, did I go in a circle?
I went in a circle.
Wait, that's what that was?
Oh, I'm in the... I went in a circle.
This is where the bridge was.
Right?
Yeah.
God fucking...
Okay.
Instant transmission.
It's the sax.
Yeah, nope, she's not working.
Kyle!
You gotta expand your horizons, Kyle!
You know what they say about eight legs, Kyle!
Thank you for the super chat, Kyle.
Thank you, thank you.
And, like, she has experience!
She must be, like, 500 years worth of experience, Kyle!
What do they say?
I'm so confused.
Look up...
The Little Mermaid Eight Legs.
I think that's right.
Then you'll know.
Sorry, what?
The Little Mermaid Eight Legs!
It's a classic!
It's a...
You guys have never seen it?
Okay, we're pausing.
You guys have never seen that video?
Okay.
The little...
There's a...
It's a whole lot of...
It's not just eight legs, but, like, there's a lot more.
It came...
It's this one.
Ariel needs legs.
Here.
This is where it comes from.
It's a classic!
It's...
Oh, shit, sorry.
I had to put on my glasses because I had to...
put on my reading glasses there.
Wait, where did...
Where did that come from?
Oh, I came in this way.
Okay.
Then I could go up then.
Don't release that cursed knowledge.
If I had to grow up with that, then you do too.
All these lines make a circle.
Michael, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, shit.
Okay, nice.
I still killed him.
You can't escape from me.
Oh, shit.
You too.
I got lost.
I lost access.
Headed east instead of west.
Send help.
Kyle, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Another Kyle?
Oh, my God.
There's Kyle A and Kyle C.
I love Kyle.
I'm going to learn things today.
Okay, here we go.
Now we can open this chest.
I couldn't watch it.
It hurts my soul.
All right.
Open.
Nice.
The long aura amplification.
More stuff I won't use.
I like that.
I like hoarding.
I don't hoard cash, I just hoard... I just hoard video game items.
Oh, I was here.
I came from here.
So... I was here.
Does that mean... Oh no!
Okay.
Alright, now!
Don't worry, I'm gonna help now.
I'm pretty sure you're done with the granny, right?
Now I can like show up, right?
I should be able to show up now.
He has to be done with the grand-grand.
Let's see.
This way.
Oh, I didn't see this pathway before.
What is this?
Wait, this is new.
Sorry, I'm gonna be going this way instead.
This is new, right?
Is this new?
This has to be new, right?
I don't remember... Oh my god, no it's not.
No, it's not new.
God fucking... God damn it.
I'm going in a circle again.
I'm going in the goddamn circle.
Alright.
And then...
We're...
How did I get from here to a circle?
Oh, he is not getting saved.
I don't know where...
Guys, I don't know where he...
I don't know how I got there.
Oh, he's so fucked.
How did I get there?
Oh my god.
I think he's just gonna have to live with her.
Monkey's lost.
Monkey is very lost right now.
Okay, so like...
This...
Wait, what?
No, it's here.
It's here.
I remember.
I killed this guy.
I remember now.
I killed him.
Okay, and then...
Where am I?
Okay, and then we...
We go down here.
Yes!
Okay, I remember now.
This is familiar.
Okay.
And this is where I saw the whole cutscene.
Yeah.
Alright, nice.
Alright.
Don't worry.
Now I figured it out.
El Mexican.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
See, I told you.
I'm a good homie.
Never leave a homie behind.
Alright.
Know when to give the homie the...
You know how like...
You're at a bad date or whatever.
And then like...
And then you're like...
Oh shit.
Like...
I need out right now.
And then your homie gives you an emergency call.
And pretends to be like...
Oh my god!
Emergency!
You need to go to the hospital.
To get you out of...
The bad situation.
I'm him.
I'm that guy.
I'm here to give you the fake phone call.
For you to leave.
Don't worry.
Don't worry, Chupacay.
Have that phone ready.
We'll give you the call.
Hahaha!
Don't worry!
I'm gonna...
Thanks, bro.
Hahaha!
xDKBrosCode66 I actually own the...
Barney Simpson bro code book.
Like...
I actually...
I have a physical hard copy of that.
Like...
So I know the bro code, guys.
Don't worry.
I'm a true bro.
I have the...
Physical hard copy edition.
Of the bro code.
Hahaha!
So I'll be there.
I'll be there for you.
Hahaha!
I'll be that bro.
That's true, bro.
Appreciate the bro mission.
Hahaha!
Holy shit!
Hey.
Why are they so fly?
Why do they...
Why are they fly like that?
What the f...
Is this an a...
Am I not supposed to be down here?
This seems scary.
Like...
Hahaha!
Bro, I will read for my bro.
I'll learn how to read for my bro.
Hahaha!
Thanks, bro.
The best romances are bromance.
That's all I'm saying.
Hahaha!
A bro will always be there for you.
Whoa, bro.
True.
He's so real.
Hahaha!
Why is there so many of you?
You're not spiders.
I cannot aim.
Oh, my God.
Bro, please.
Please.
Please!
Oh, my God.
You guys are so fucking annoying.
Holy shit.
I will use my magic to get out of the way.
Okay.
Nice.
These guys are actually...
Oh, and then there's big worm!
Oh, shit!
There's way too many...
There's way too many things on my screen right now.
I cannot deal with this.
There's way too many things on my screen.
There's...
There's way...
I will poke you.
Okay.
Nice.
All right.
Okay.
We're okay.
We're...
We are...
Okay.
What the fuck is this baby doing here?
This is not your battle!
Girl!
Go through puberty first!
This is literally not your fight!
Oh, please don't tell me they respawn.
Like...
Like, why is there another one?
Okay.
Nice.
All right.
I won't fucking use my magic.
I can't.
I cannot deal with these guys!
Okay.
Nice.
Get them out of here.
Goodbye!
All right.
Nice.
I assume these are all worms, right?
If not, I'm just gonna...
That has to be a worm.
That looks like a...
Oh!
Oh, shit!
What the fuck?
What a bait!
I got baited so hard there.
Wait, there's more of the other ones?
Okay.
This is not good.
This is it.
Fuck this.
I'm gonna send in reinforcements.
Go.
Do your thing.
I don't wanna fight anymore.
I'm gonna...
What's it called when you, like...
Do they respawn?
Do these guys respawn?
It's like, why is there another one?
I don't know.
You know, like, when you...
When you get work and then you give it to somebody else to do for a cheaper price?
I'm doing that right now with my little monkeys.
I...
No, no, no.
Outsourcing.
Yeah, I'm outsourcing.
I'm outsourcing my duties right now to the other monkeys.
I mean, you just rip a few of your hairs and then you get cheap labor right there.
Oh.
Better be like...
Can I rob this man's grave?
Okay.
Just gotta make sure.
Yes, I can.
Thank god.
Okay.
Wait.
There's somebody above me?
Where?
Oh, there.
What the fuck?
Oh, free labor.
Oh my god.
That's better than cheap labor.
Alright.
Robbing this children's grave.
Okay.
Nice.
They're dead already.
They don't need the gold anymore.
Even though, like, technically in, like, um, in, like, Chinese...
Uh...
What?
How are you invisible?
In...
Even though, technically, in China, when you, when you bury something in the grave, it's supposed to...
Or, like, burn stuff and put in the grave or whatever, um, it technically goes with them to heaven.
So, like, now they don't have the item anymore.
So...
It can't be that important, you know?
It can't be that...
I used to do that when I used to live in Asia.
Um...
Because it's, like, a...
I don't remember what it's called, but it's, like, a special day where a bunch of family would go to visit the graves and then go and burn, like, those, like, paper...
Um...
Burn, like, specific paper that's shaped, like, different types of stuff.
And to, like, give these items to the...
Um...
To the dead.
It's not just paper money.
It's, like, they're, like, shaped, like...
They're, like, shaped, like, uh, certain items and stuff.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, that festival.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
And, like, there's, like, a special, uh...
There's, like, a special area.
Because, like, the higher...
There's, like, some grave sites where...
You know how, like, in Western culture, um, grave sites are, like, usually just, like, plotted land in the...
In...
In the middle?
Like, it's just, like, flat?
Uh...
Or, like, those, like...
Like, cemetery...
Castle thingies?
I don't know what they're called.
Like...
Yeah, it's, like, a...
A bank transfer to your ancestor.
Yeah, so...
So, but in, um...
In Chinese culture, the higher your grave is to the sky, um, the closer they are to heaven.
So, like...
To...
To be higher.
Instead of, like...
Like...
We don't do it flat.
We make...
We make it so that if you get the higher, uh, plotted land, then you're closer to heaven.
So, it, like, considered, like, you're, like...
It's, like, higher status and stuff like that.
Which is really interesting.
Um...
And I would go, like...
I remember...
Oh, my God.
Then you can buy, like...
I remember because, like, when the iPhone came out, they released those, like, paper iPhones.
So, I remember, like, going there.
And then...
And then, uh...
Uh...
And then...
My mom...
I think, like, my parents were, like, it's time to give grandma an iPhone.
And then we would burn these, like, iPhones and, like, clothes and, like...
And stuff.
It's so fun.
It's so cute and funny at the same time.
I think it's just a nice thought, you know?
Like, your ancestors get to have, like, iPhones and stuff, too, up there by burning a paper iPhone.
Yeah, it's so cute.
I love it.
That was cute.
And, like, it's, like...
You can burn, like, bags and, like...
There's, like...
And it's so...
It's so cute, too, because there's, like, designer paper...
Like, there's, like, things where you can, like, burn, like, things that look like designer bags or clothes.
And you, like...
Let's give grandma good clothes, you know?
What's grandma gonna do with an iPhone?
I mean, she can go play games on the iPhone and go through...
Go do the internet stuff.
Yeah.
And then you burn money, so it's, like, you give, like, a bank transfer to your ancestors, too.
But, like, the default is, like, paper money.
Like, not actual money, but it's, like...
Like, God money.
Like...
Like, heaven money.
She can be a gamer in heaven.
Oh, shit.
I always thought...
I thought that was, like, really interesting.
Oh, no.
I'm stuck.
Please.
The heavenly cash.
Yeah.
Heavenly cash.
Oh, God.
Damn it.
I just...
I need...
One at a time, guys.
One at a time.
I haven't done...
I haven't, uh...
Uh...
Visited the graves in a while, though, since I haven't been in Asia in a long time.
Because of COVID.
So, like...
Because, like, when everything...
I used to visit...
Uh...
Visit Asia...
Um...
Once a year.
Or, like, every other year.
But ever since, like, COVID happened, like, I haven't traveled a lot.
I haven't gone...
I haven't been able to travel.
So, it'd be nice.
I really wanna go back eventually when things cool down.
I am gonna die.
Where the fuck is, like...
Oh, I'm poisoned.
Guys, I'm gonna die from poison.
I'm actually gonna die from poison.
Where is the shrine?
Oh my god!
It's right in front of me!
Oh, damn!
Okay.
I died, like, right in front of the shrine.
Uh, it would be so sad.
I...
I would be...
I would be so sad if I actually died in front of it.
Holy shit!
That was close.
That was...
That was so close.
Oh, my god.
Yes.
I'm gonna do the spellbinding.
I think I'm gonna die.
I think, like, spellbinding helps a lot.
I'm gonna...
Redo my spells.
Okay.
Um...
Spellbinder.
Okay.
I think the spellbinder is pretty cool.
Last minute situation.
I was like, where is it?
Thank god.
Okay.
Thank god I got it in time.
Thank god.
Can I obtain materials from...
Dude, I don't really need materials.
Okay.
Spellbinder.
Is this?
No, that's pluck.
Fuck is my spellbinder?
Alright.
Give me my spellbinder.
I don't need immobilize anymore.
Uh...
How do I get rid of you?
I forgot.
Uh...
I need a...
Oh, wait.
I think it's, like, on the shrine.
Uh...
It's a reignite.
Okay.
There you go.
Yeah.
I'd love to, like, uh...
Go back whenever...
I haven't been able to go back after COVID was over.
Well, not over, but, like, you know...
Ha!
Manageable now.
Like, I think that's a more appropriate word because we all know it's not over.
Like...
Um...
Okay.
Oh, I guess I have to do all of it.
Uh...
I've just been so busy.
I've been so busy.
I haven't even had a chance to go back.
Okay.
Let's see.
Oh, yeah.
Now I have to redo this, too.
Uh...
Increases the damage of the next attack after dodge.
Slight increases attack.
Increases invincibility when seeing through.
Increases frost damage.
Increases attack.
Okay.
Nice.
Alright.
I wanted to use spellbinder because, like, I like to unga bunga more.
Um...
But I want to, like, to go back.
When, like, things calm down in my life and I...
Like, I have my life under control.
No reason why I haven't, like, traveled or really...
I've only traveled for business.
I haven't traveled for leisure in a long time.
So, like, I'm hoping I can travel again soon.
Because I want to go back to Asia.
Um...
And just, like, you know...
Just for pleasure.
Oh!
Goodbye, spiders!
Wrong way!
But there's this guy in front of me!
How is there another way?
But he's guarding the door!
How can it be a wrong way?
When he's literally trying to guard the door!
All right.
That's looking right.
I'm strong now.
That's...
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Like, I am strong, though.
But, like, give me a sec, bro.
Give me a sec.
Okay.
Nice.
All right.
I'm still strong, though.
It's just, you know...
It's just unfortunate that you got that hit in.
There's a back door?
Okay.
Now you're fucking with me.
There's no one.
There's no way.
He's literally guarding the door.
All right.
Off we go.
Ooh.
Hey.
Is he a pig?
Oh, no.
He's a bug.
Okay.
You're...
He's still alive.
Okay.
I wasn't too late.
Oh, it's him again!
Oh, shit!
It's the light guy!
His only job is to provide light!
Wait.
How am I already in another shrine?
What?
Wait.
Maybe I did go the wrong way.
Why is there another shrine so fast?
Why is there another shrine?
Why did I already get to another shrine?
Is there actually another way?
I don't know.
He was right!
No!
And we made fun of him!
I got...
We made fun of him for being right.
Wait.
But which way is it?
I don't even remember.
Okay.
This is where I came from.
So, apparently, there's a crack somewhere.
I have to...
Go.
Dragoons never lie.
Wait.
Then...
Where would it...
Is it here?
Where would the fucking crack be?
Vindication.
He was right!
Oh.
Go back.
Okay.
Oh.
Is it here?
Can I...
No.
This is just a wall.
Before the shrine?
Oh.
Before the shrine.
It should be like...
Somewhere here?
No.
Not here.
So, it should be...
Ow.
Bro.
Stop.
Not cool, bro.
Oh.
This one.
There it is.
Oh my god.
It's such a tiny crack!
Alright.
Okay.
Nice.
Up we go.
Oh!
It's just...
There's no boss here.
It's just to meditate.
What do you mean?
Do you think...
Do you think my bro is done with Granny Spotter?
Or do you think he needs more time?
I don't know when to call the phone yet.
He never specify when I should call.
He's dead.
You said I should call, but I don't know when I should do it.
Like, bro.
I don't...
I don't know.
Should I bring water?
Like...
Okay.
Let's see.
We go...
Oh.
There's another.
There is!
Which way?
Okay.
I came from this way.
So, this is where the boss should be.
Okay.
This meditation is wild!
Alright, let's get him out of the way.
Don't fall.
I swear.
Okay.
Thank God.
I didn't wanna fall.
I was worried there.
Oh, hey.
There's another thingy.
Bro didn't give me the code word.
Not the safe word, bro.
Because like, bro...
You're making it weird, bro.
Bro...
Like, don't call it a safe word, bro.
That's fucking weird.
Oh, there it is.
It's another frog!
No!
They're gonna... I'm gonna get judged again!
Not the frog!
I'm gonna get critiques on my boss plays because of a fucking frog!
Not again!
No!
Not the frog again!
They're gonna fucking... They're gonna brain fade me again!
You know the script!
No!
Oh god.
No.
I'm gonna get that message again, guys.
I'm gonna...
One
guy is gonna be back in the comments!
I lose for the views.
Here comes the frog.
No!
I don't even remember... Okay, this is the way.
The frog strikes again.
God fucking dammit.
She followed the script.
Why is it always the frogs?
Here comes the content farm!
Guys, I only lost because I'm just farming content, guys.
That's the...
Guys, I only lost because I just wanted to farm some content.
I can't, like, use the transform before anything.
I need to get rid of him, though.
This guy is pissing me off.
Wow!
Okay.
Alright, I guess we do that again.
I'm always two steps ahead, guys.
Two steps ahead.
Alright.
Off back at it again.
Guys, I failed it out there before content chat.
Because I knew that people would be like, hee hee ha ha.
And then...
And then viewship goes up.
Two steps ahead.
I'm always two steps ahead.
Alright, where the fuck is this goddamn frog?
Okay, this way.
Alright, there he is.
There he fucking is.
Looking at me like that.
God dammit, I'm coming over.
Alright.
Nice.
Heavy attack!
Oh shit!
Did I hit that?
I hope I did.
Oh shit, okay.
This guy does so much damage.
Holy shit.
It's okay.
Alright, that's fine.
That's fine.
It's not my actual HP anyway.
We're still in it.
We're still in it!
That's fucking...
Alright, now we're not.
Now we're not.
And now I transform.
Wait, I have been done!
Baby, it's a kind of bug!
No!
No, I forgot about baby!
He crashed me!
I did not!
Did he crash me?
Where did my HP go?
Where did it all go?
Bugs!
Hey.
She's always three steps ahead, guys.
Three steps ahead.
Okay.
Back at her.
I wish the frog was closer.
Oh my god.
Kyle, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It makes you feel any better.
There are two more frogs and you can cultivate the spirit to make it stronger.
What?
Why are the frogs so strong?
Bro, I'm already having a bad day, bro!
Fuck off!
Actually...
Fuck off.
Alright, not cool, bro.
Not fucking cool.
Guys, it's been a while.
So I need to use the...
I need to remember to use the baby.
Okay.
Alright.
Here we go.
Here we go again.
Jesus Christ.
Okay.
Oh my god, why are you so...
Why are you just slapping me?
Oh shit.
He's so fucking strong.
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
He's just slapping, too.
Like, he's just slapping.
Okay, here we go again.
We got a lot of progress done.
Nice.
Nice, alright, here we go.
This is fine.
We made a lot of progress.
It's alright.
And then big baby time.
Big baby!
That's fucking right!
And then one!
Alright, okay, now we just gotta make sure he doesn't start boring.
Like, that's...
That's really it!
Oh my god.
Please, sir.
Please.
Please, I beg of you.
I... Please, how did you do that much damage?!
Are you fucking kidding me?!
Stop!
Please... Please...
Ow!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, please, I don't want to be any more steps ahead.
Oh no!
He fucking grabbed me!
I got his frog!
Stupid fucking...
I can't believe he grabbed me.
I do okay on the others!
It's just...
The frogs are like my kryptonite.
I don't know what it is about them.
Like, they just do these frog things and I don't know what to do.
I don't know what to do when he starts doing frog things.
They... They just...
Just exist and I don't know!
Frozen, thank you for the...
Oh my god, I went the wrong way.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
This has shown us that frogs are the real ultimate life form.
Reject monkey.
Oh my god, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yoko, thank you for the super chat.
It's always the frogs.
Zeon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
If it's any consolation to the last two...
There's more frogs?
Like... Oh my god!
Somebody stop these frogs!
Find where they live!
Somebody stop them before it's too late.
Find where... Find the babies.
Subscribed.
Girls.
Smells.
Sounds.
Like remained, pieces.
Like...
I was so scared.
I was so scared of missing because I was like, that seems like something I would do, you know?
Oh god, please.
Please.
Please, I'm trying to regen right now.
Are you fucking kidding me?
I keep fucking spitting, so god, okay.
Okay.
Like, what is that?
I can't even hit him!
Oh my god, please.
Stop!
Oh no.
No!
Deepfucking...
No.
No!
Leave me alone, please!
Just leave me alone!
I can barely hit him!
Jesus Christ!
God damn it, please!
He has a belly flop!
No, no, no, no.
Oh my god, bro.
What the fuck are his attacks, man?
No, please!
Please!
Oh my god!
No!
Oh!
Oh, we did it!
We did it!
We're four steps ahead!
Oh my god, and I took his kids, too!
Damn right, I'm gonna fucking steal your children!
I'm gonna steal your children!
Burrito!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
I have to say, she is too weak.
I've seen girls play Black Muffin.
Their invasion skills are good.
But Doki died.
I'm fine.
Four times!
Jayden, update your meme!
To a damn ice cream parlor!
I have to say, Doki's skill is too bad.
Is she deliberately profaming?
Being abused to increase viewers?
Thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god.
That's fucking right.
I stole his kids.
Thank fucking god I stole his...
Oh, and then there's...
Oh my god, please.
Instant transmission.
I can't.
I need a heal.
Affiliate, thank you for the 10 gifted shoes.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright.
At least I got my heals in.
Oh, thank god.
Okay.
Oh, travel.
And then we'll go back to there.
Yeah, I saw it.
He ate the left hand bug.
Oh, he ate the twin brother!
Hey, at least we'll see each other in heaven.
Or hell, I don't know where the monsters go.
Where the guys go.
Okay.
Alright.
This is... Oh, there he is!
We're here!
We're here for the wedding!
Woah, why is this so quiet?
I thought this was a wedding, girls.
Ladies, ladies.
Woah.
What's going on?
I thought this was a wedding.
I thought this was a banquet.
Where's the food?
Oh.
Was it that good?
Oh, it was that good.
He's like, why did you interrupt my...
Bro, I'm sorry!
Bro, you told me to call you, bro!
I didn't know you didn't give me a sign!
It was...
Oh my god, bro!
I didn't know, bro!
You didn't give me the signal, bro!
I still... You still needed me there!
Bro, I didn't know!
Bro, I'm sorry!
You can go back to the granny!
Oh, shit!
Oh my god, he is mad!
He is actually... I'm so sorry, man.
He is so mad.
He's so mad at me, guys.
I interrupted him.
I'm so sorry.
Bro, you didn't leave the sock!
How was I supposed to know, Juwaka?
You didn't leave the sock or anything!
Like, I... I wouldn't know!
Oh my god.
Oh, this was a bad time for me.
That's for sure.
Holy shit, now he's spitting!
Okay, nice.
Bam!
Alright, nice.
Okay.
I need to regen, though.
Oh, he's spitting.
Oh, what the fuck!
The spin-spin.
Did she tell you that?
I've never seen that move before.
Holy shit.
The granny did teach you new stuff.
Oh my god.
Granny did teach you some new moves, bro.
In battle, too?
Like...
Spin to win.
Yeah.
Well that'd be pretty sweet, right?
That'd be pretty cool.
Yeah.
I'm really  judged today.
You guys are in your th Commercials newsroom on Slack for our show.
My
character is the ghost behaviors!
See, that's what's so funny!
But like, in the beginning, it was only things that I couldUBor house as a child.
Sometimes you just wait, and then make a relationship, or have a relationship.
We made a group and we match up.
Then you come out of the two, and they're like...
All out!
And I was like...
You're definitely not 15, right Yeah, actually I am 15.
Broke the ultimate bro code!
You let a hoe get in between the bros!
Give me a sec, I'm breaking a few pots.
Broke the bro code.
Alright, can't be that good, bro!
Bro, we need to play... What happened to GameCube night, man?
What am I gonna play GameCube with next?
I'm gonna play on the Xbox with Halo!
Where do I go?
Left or right?
Like, where did he fly to?
Up?
Oh, okay.
I couldn't tell where he flew to.
Up here?
Oh.
Go in.
Oh shit, I should have healed.
Okay.
We don't hang out anymore, bro.
Okay, let's go back in here.
What about LAN nights, bro?
Ever since you met that... that granny spider lady.
We don't do LAN nights anymore.
You always say, like, next time.
But that's... that's been two... that's been two months, bro.
When will we ever have next time?
Hahahaha!
The bro's been offline for seven years!
Oh, that hurt, man.
You've been offline for seven years, bro.
I haven't seen you on the Xbox last online.
Seven years ago.
I like how the music got a little depressing, too.
Hahahaha!
It's always you two.
When is it us two?
Bro, when I said I wanted to hang out, I didn't mean you have to bring her along.
Hahahaha!
Getting too real.
Oh my god, again?
Are you dead?
My love, this is all because of you!
Real homies are happy for them, but it doesn't hurt less!
You're going to just abandon me, you bitch.
You won't make me leave, again?
Bro, I can still be in your life, bro.
Like... You don't have to choose me or her.
I just need to!
Bro!
Bro, Mad Nights, man!
Jesus, why is he so tanky?
Holy shit!
Wait, he's actually so tanky, guys.
Like, my shit...
We just miss you, bro!
Like...
You haven't... you haven't seen your friends in, like, months, man!
Like, we just wanna know what's going on!
Like, you need a life outside of her, too!
It's not just... her!
Okay.
I'm gonna make sure I have my stamina, too.
Is there no joy for me then?
There's no joy for anyone!
Shit!
That's real.
That's so real.
Oh my god.
That's so fucking real.
Holy shit, man.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, it's so hard to roll!
The mud is making it so hard to roll!
Wait, did I get a halfway point?
Is it phase two?
Thank god, Mime.
That's messed up.
The face too?
What the fuck is go- Bro, you okay?
Ohh!
He got- He's got the real ping in him!
Bro!
He's- Morb he's got- Oh my god, he's going feral.
He's going feral for her!
Bro!
We can share!
We can share time together, man!
Like, I- I'm not trying to say, like, God ping you!
Me or her!
Like we... I'm just saying!
You're fully picking her!
And like, we just were just concerned!
Holy shit!
How do I...
I awakened the inner pig.
You went full feral.
Like it's not healthy, bro!
Oh my god!
That was... that was hard!
The mud is so hard to... hard to like dodge.
Take his wife's name out of your mouth.
You went full hog.
Yeah, the mud fight... the mud part was really hard.
It was really difficult.
I didn't know how to dodge that.
Alright, he's... he's... he's... he's fucking a spirit form right now.
What?
Oh wait, he does?
That's fucked.
That's mad.
That's... that's fucked up, bro.
Like, how was I supposed to know you were gonna do that?
Oh my god.
Wait, what?
I've never seen that before!
What the fuck is that?
That's new.
Holy... that was new.
I was not ready for that.
Wait, what can I... oh, I can't even fight him outside.
I have to fight him in the mud.
Ooh, I think that's the worst part.
How the fuck... how is he... like... fish?
I've never seen the fish form until now.
How many patterns does he have?
No, not the tornado!
Okay, thank god.
Okay, he messed up the tornado.
Oh no.
Okay.
Please, let me...
Okay, nice.
I got it.
I need a heal though.
Nice.
Okay, he's got that pig in him.
He can transform, yeah.
Is this what hag might actually does to a bro?
Bro.
Okay.
Guys, I don't want to see his pig form again.
He can, like, be here.
Wow!
Okay, that... I got fucked up by the camera, guys.
You guys can't blame me for that.
The camera actually fucked me up, bro.
What?!
That's messed up.
No, not the catfish.
No.
Not the fish.
Not the fish!
Okay.
Can I, like, be here?
Would I be fine?
I think so.
Nice.
Okay.
Okay, I got that hit in though.
Oh, I didn't mean to heal, but that's alright.
Okay.
I think I'm...
What the fuck?
He's a rhino?!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, there's so many rhinos!
Oh shit!
Okay.
This transformation is bullshit.
But what...
How did she able to do that when he met her?
What the fuck?
You've been holding out on me?!
You learned all these moves for her?!
God, I can't dodge jack shit.
Okay.
No, no no.
Please, please.
Please.
Please, he's so low.
Yes!
Oh my god!
No!
No.
WHAT AM I MISSING?!
WHAT?!
HE'S LIKE WHAT?!
YOU SHOULD BE DEAD!
I KNOW WHAT HE SAID!
HE GOT AWAY?!
Okay, that's actually bullshit.
That's actually bullshit.
HE DOESN'T STOP!
Now, there we go.
There we go!
It sounds like...
Oh my gosh!
I'm sorry!
I'm sorry for insulting your girlfriend, bro.
Or your wife.
I'm sorry!
Bro goes down when he goes down.
Look at yourself!
Look what you became!
Look at what granny!
Granny spider!
Made you!
What the fuck?
You used to be like him.
There's a broken chain.
Look what it glanced into you!
He was hot?
Bro.
Always has been.
What do you mean, was?
Oh my gosh, she took him back.
Every time we have a breakthrough, she takes him back.
And then I have to start all over again.
Alright, nice.
We got the bloodstained needle.
Anything I have to get from here?
Not again.
No!
I had a breakthrough!
Now she's got it and lit her eight legs on him again!
Alright.
We open this chest.
Round two.
I think we're past round two.
I didn't break any chains.
We took a while to get to him, guys.
I don't think he's at... There's definitely not single digits anymore.
Alright.
Craft armor.
Nice.
We have new... We finally have new armor.
40.
Pure broken mask.
Mud that stains.
Damage reductions.
Oh, okay.
Oh, 79!
Let's fucking go.
Let's go.
Confirmed.
Oh, I look so badass with the new one.
And then...
Wait, what am I missing?
Find gold thread?
Can I buy that?
Find gold thread.
Oh, I can.
Nice.
Wait, I can?
It's sold out?
No!
It is sold out!
Sell out!
Is that hard to spin gold?
What do you mean?
Wait, this tiger has... Oh, you're right.
Tiger might have some.
I'll go visit a tiger.
I can't believe it.
Who bought all the gold threads?
Who bought it?
I don't think you need it more than me, guys.
I don't I'm on a mission to save a bro right now.
Are you on a mission to save a bro?
Tiger does it?
God damn it.
What's the point?
I guess I'll go back then.
I guess...
Oh yeah, I'll get in chapter five then.
Alright, let's see.
I'm gonna go grab some water.
I'll be right back.
Yeah, I fought him.
He broke my PC, but I fought him.
My PC has never been the same since I fought that guy.
He legitimately fucked it up.
I don't know what he did.
But my PC has never been the same.
Alright, stay hydrated, everybody.
Oh, I commissioned some new emotes.
I commissioned ten new emotes yesterday.
I don't know when they'll be done, but look forward to some new emotes when they get here.
They might not be done for a bit though, because artists are busy, busy.
Let's see.
Where do I go?
Absorb.
Please don't tell me there's a phase three.
Whoa.
Statues.
There are places I... Where do I go?
Alan and Kaz, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It's so quiet.
I don't like that.
I don't like how quiet it is here.
Whoa!
I didn't see this guy.
Get over here.
Alright, nice.
Spoilers?
One of them?
What did I...
Oh, one of them is the loading.
So when I'm AFK, it'll be the loading emote.
That's one of them.
That's all I'll tell you.
But like, for the first time in a long time, I'm actually catching up.
I'm actually almost caught up with everything.
It's been so long since I've had like the...
Wait, who's shooting me?
I've been able to have that, you know, being able to catch up to myself.
Who's he?
Is he bad guy?
Are you a bad guy?
Oh.
Okay.
That's not creepy at all.
Gather?
What am I gathering?
Shock.
Shack.
Pusk.
Choice.
What is that?
What the fuck did I put in my hand?
Not some dead foot!
I'm not gonna read that out loud!
But thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Oh, hey!
Lightman!
This is like his minimum wage job and I'm ruining it for him.
I'm like this punk that decided like...
He's like that!
He's like those like...
Horror... you know like those people working at haunted houses and then I'm that guy that punched him.
Like that's basically what's going on.
I'm that freak that punched a haunted house employee.
Like...
You know like now you have to sign... whenever you go on a haunted house you have a lot...
Not a lot but some haunted houses now you have to sign a contract or a waiver where like you're not allowed to like they can pursue legal action on you if you punch the haunted house like scarers.
Yeah!
Cause people do that!
People like...
Cause you know you're scaring them.
So like you know they do fight or flight.
So then sometimes you know you get pushed or like punched if you're working at a haunted house.
So now like you have to actually sign waivers now.
So like you're like okay.
Like you're not allowed to punch or push or like touch touch the people doing like the scares.
Or like you have to pay like a fine.
Which is understandable!
Whoa.
Oh there's a big scorpion man.
I don't like how there's so many eggs here.
I should upgrade.
Almost forgot to upgrade.
Okay I gotta make sure to upgrade these too.
Self advance.
Okay what do I wanna advance?
I guess like my stuff here.
Oh my god I have not advanced these.
Definitely.
Let's see.
Each tile increases the charging.
Okay yeah.
I feel like I should charge that up.
Reduces the...
Okay.
Yeah I don't wanna take less of that.
And then perfect dodges.
Stamina cost.
When health.
Each tile increases stamina when health is above half.
I don't wanna upgrade.
Oh critical hit.
You know I don't get critical hit.
Ooh.
Absorb.
Okay.
Oh shit!
The fuck?
That's creepy.
The ladies don't like that.
Whoa.
What the fuck?
Why did you see me there?
That's fucking right.
I'm gonna go right in.
Oh shit!
Okay.
Guess not.
I guess I don't go right in.
Oh my god.
Oh my god I do so...
Oh my god!
Why do you do so much damage?
Okay nice.
He's dead.
Jesus Christ I took so much damage there.
Is it because of him?
Oh I'm coming over.
Oh you made a mistake bitch.
You fucking made... Oh yeah!
Yeah it was him.
Guys it was...
Guys it was definitely him.
Now I know.
Now I realize why.
I was like what?
How did I lose like half my HP?
That makes more sense.
I was so confused.
Alright.
Stop bro get some help.
Ladies don't like it when you stand there in the dark man.
Alright.
If you think...
If you think it's the lady's fault.
That like...
That you haven't got anybody yet.
Maybe don't stand in the dark.
Waiting for me to show up.
Alright.
Oh no not you.
God damn it.
Alright.
It's alright.
He can't touch me.
Oh shit there he goes.
Unless you're Batman.
But I don't think... I don't think that guy was Batman guys.
I...
Guys I don't think he was Batman.
Unless you have millions of dollars.
Or billions.
And you can stand there in the creepy hallway.
Wait what the... Oh it's him.
It's like what?
These guys are so weak.
Alright.
I'm not afraid of these guys.
Because they're so easy to kill.
Alright.
Up we go.
I'm still trying to journey to find my bro.
I haven't seen him since he met that spider granny.
Two years ago.
The bro.
Journey to the bro.
It's not journey to the west anymore guys.
Alright.
Up we go.
Still up we go.
Jesus how fucking high is this mountain?
Bro first before the west.
True.
I told you guys.
This is the bro code.
I ain't breaking that shit.
Stay hydrated.
Alright.
Nice.
We gotta go this way.
Hello?
Bro?
I'm knocking just to make sure you guys have time.
To like...
So I'm not interrupting anything.
Back in the days of the monkey.
Who was the one that saved me from being killed by a fool?
Who was the one that didn't give you a hand in the end?
I didn't forget.
But what I can't forget is after you guys left.
How I can get over the blood and flesh of the sisters.
This grudge cannot be all on us.
If you want to blame it, blame your bro.
He was the one who put Tang Sen Rou
We had a hundred kids, Chewbacca!
Bros before hoes!
You don't understand!
I knew it bro!
I knew you wouldn't betray me bro!
I knew it!
He's still there!
He's just jealous of us bro!
Wow bro!
Do you still want me here?
You guys are still not happy?
You're not done?
What?
Who is she?
Is that the newest daughter?
What?
What the fuck?
Why did you make her?
That's your dad that abandoned you.
Your father said you did!
Oh shit!
It's child support time!
Why did your father hurt?
That's your kid!
That's literally your kid!
I hate monkeys!
You guys always ruin my life!
Pay up!
It's time to pay up!
He wants a DNA test!
Hey!
Wow!
Bro!
It's just... bro!
Don't make this weird!
Oh my god!
Why did you make this weird?
We're just bros!
Wait!
What's the difference?
I don't know.
It's my fault!
Bro!
My fault!
Bro.
Dude.
Bro!
Oh shit!
That's a lot of damage.
Nice.
That's so much, I just realized.
Oh my god!
Cheat jobs?!
That's cheating.
That's cheating, actually.
Big baby!
Whoa!
Did I do it?
Okay, I did.
I spellbind in time.
Thank god.
Oh my god, I don't know, like, her thing.
Like, oh it's so confusing.
I'm trying to figure out what her...
Oh, I'm trying to figure out her patterns, but she has so many legs.
It's like really hard to figure out the pattern because of how many legs she has.
It's just a lot of legs!
Guys, it's everywhere!
Like, it's understandable!
Legs for days!
Bro, she has more than... wait, does she have eight?
Like, I think she has more than eight.
Oh my
god, that was close.
That was actually... what the fuck?
That was close.
Too many!
Too many legs!
That's a way to go!
Oh my god.
Holy fuck, bro!
Bro, not in front of him!
That's weird.
That... what?!
That insta kills me?!
Fuck!
I literally just stood there!
I can't believe that kills me!
Oh my god!
Okay, that shit was... that was a lot of damage.
That was a lot of damage.
I came from there, okay.
For some context, Bakae knows she's his kid, but heaven forbids mingling with Gwae.
Acknowledging her will probably get her hunted down.
Zero, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
See ya is all out of love.
Like, he could secretly... like, he might not... hey, maybe they're not watching right now, you know?
Maybe they're...
Maybe... maybe they're not watching right now, you don't know that, you know?
Oh my god.
Verita!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Jesus.
Oh my god.
Jeez, this does so much damage.
Better watch it, you don't wanna die here.
But I'm doing this all for you, man.
And you're... even though you don't... you don't... you don't wanna pay for the child support, but I'm still here.
Did I miss?
I fucking missed.
God damn it.
Jesus Christ!
I can't!
Oh my god, bro!
Okay!
He's just too many legs.
Like, I'm actually losing track of how to fight this.
I'm losing track.
There's just way too many legs.
Like, it's actually disorienting me.
No!
Please!
Flicko and me not in front of him!
Not only on Wednesdays!
Oh my god, please, I can't even heal.
I can't even heal, man.
I can't even heal.
Oh my god!
Bro!
Bro, please!
I can't get out of here!
Oh my god, I know I should saspin, but like, I... guys, like...
Oh god, oh, she's gonna explode.
Oh shit!
This is so crazy.
He's so... Oh my god!
The spider!
I don't... I don't... I'm gonna get the freeze.
No, Raijin, I'm getting the freeze.
No, fuck this.
I'm using magic.
Oh, no!
Okay.
I'm using magic.
I'm res... I'm swapping.
I can't.
I can't get close to her.
Okay.
I could barely get close to her, guys.
Like, I need to use this.
Okay.
Alright.
Okay, I need to get rid of one.
Can I just get rid of one?
Okay, reclaim.
Nice.
Okay, I'll get rid of...
I wanna get rid of...
I'll get rid of... What did I...
I'll get... Oh, actually, I'll get rid of... this.
And then I'll put that in here.
Okay.
Alright.
And then I'll swap it.
I can't.
We need the freeze.
It was too much.
Too much.
Okay.
Set spells.
Immobilize.
And then we'll use magic.
Alright, here we go.
She's like that in the bedroom.
I can see how he went a little...
Oh, I haven't started it.
Oh, thank God.
I haven't.
Oh, I haven't started it.
It's okay.
She didn't see me.
Bro, why did you leave?
Bro, bro.
She didn't see me, guys.
She didn't see me.
There we go.
Now we start it.
Thank God.
Thank God she didn't see me, guys.
Okay, nice.
Okay.
Nice, alright.
We're off to a good start, guys.
We're off to a good start.
Okay, nice.
Guys, it's just... I don't know.
It's just too much movement.
I'm seeing too much movement, so it disorients me so much.
It's just something about all these lings is distracting me.
Don't lie to me.
This is what happened to you two.
Like, look at all these kids she has.
You know.
Okay, nice.
Okay.
After I get this down, I can get the babies in.
And then...
Oh, no.
Please.
No!
Fuck you!
Fuck.
Okay.
I missed again, guys.
It's alright.
Monk, babe.
Monkeys, go in.
Monkeys, go in and do your thing while I figure this out.
Go do your thing, monkeys.
Yes, hit her.
Oh, God, please.
Just do your thing while I figure this out, monkeys.
I don't...
Why is she still on me?
Why is she...
Why is she still on...
Monkeys, I thought you're supposed to do your thing.
But...
Why is she still on me, monkeys?
You're supposed to do your thing.
Oh, my God.
Oh.
Oh, man.
She's so fucking scary.
What?
What?!
Oh god!
No, I dodged it!
Thank god!
Okay, I dodged it.
That's good.
I dodged it.
That shit is scary.
That shit is actually scary.
What?!
What is that?!
What the fuck is that?!
What did she do?!
Oh!
Why?!
What the fuck do I do here?!
What is that?!
What is this?!
Why does this get me out of here?!
Oh my god.
How do I get out?
Oh my god, how was I supposed to know I was gonna get trapped in a web?!
No.
Oh no, please.
Jesus.
She's so... she is so difficult.
She is.
Come on, get over here.
I'm just gonna use this.
I'm just...
Okay, now that I know that does that, I'm definitely...
Oh, nice.
Okay.
Oh, I'm halfway.
Come on!
You're so good!
Okay.
No!
Get me out!
She missed, I think!
No!
No, I wanted to heal!
Get out.
Oh, get me out of here.
I had to use that because I got scared.
I got scared.
Oh my god, I...
I forgot to heal.
Oh my god, I also wanted to heal instead.
Oh!
Oh my god!
So low!
I missed it!
Oh, I'm sorry about your wife, bro.
She was crazy.
She has a relic?
What does she have?
Even I would go...
What the...
Oh my god!
How many kids?
I thought you had one!
This is not one!
This was not one!
Oh, this is absolutely not one!
This is not...
This is not one!
How many rounds?
Run, Forrest, run!
Oh my god!
Oh, I'm running as fast as I can!
I'm running so fast!
First floor!
Oh my god!
That man had stamina for days!
He can't pay...
I understand now.
I understand why he couldn't pay for all the child support.
I understand now why he couldn't pay for all the child support.
I understand now why he refused to acknowledge them.
They got pretty busy.
Oh, it's her!
It's the goth lady.
The goth lady was so mad.
I don't have any polygons.
Hello.
I got saved.
Temple of yellow flowers.
Hi, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Where's the flamethrower spell when you need it?
Bro, that wasn't one.
I thought it was one child.
When she was like, Grab your sisters!
I thought it'd be like, you know, 15 at like, at most.
That was not 15.
Oh my god.
He really got busy.
Okay, nice.
We finally got the gold thread so we can put this on.
It turned out he had a lot of child support to pay.
A lot.
Okay, not that.
Oh, is this?
80?
Let's...
After seeing through the enemy?
I feel like my...
Can you just stay focused for a brief moment after seeing through the enemy?
Wait.
I feel like the...
Does my staff is...
Isn't my staff better?
Isn't this better?
Yeah, this is better.
Oh!
Hey, upgrade!
Alright, let's get that.
Yeah, this is better.
Alright.
Nice.
Now we're okay again.
Alright.
And we got a fragment Vaan!
Now we talk to pretty lady.
Hello, pretty lady.
You saved us from your crazy mom.
Well, you're not a lady.
Oh!
Okay.
He's not a good guy too.
I just looked at him because I was like, What?
Okay.
Who are you?
I was like, who are you?
Yeah.
I don't remember you.
No, but thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you.
Hi, Doki.
I just got a good turn of fortune.
And since I don't have to pay spider child support, I thought I'd send some your way.
Thank you.
Thank you for the magenta soup.
Am I the child support?
I'm the child support experience.
Thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you.
I'm glad you got some good fortune your way.
All right.
Nice.
These guys are weak because they're people.
You guys are so weak.
Look at you.
You're people.
Look at your fleshy bodies.
Fly whisk Dallas.
Yeah.
He's too fleshy.
He's not a threat.
All right.
Get him out of the way.
Whoa.
What the fuck?
You barely do any damage, bro.
It's so sad.
Oh, shit.
Hey.
I'm going to steal your stuff too.
Nice.
I stole his stuff.
It's mine now.
Oh my god.
Which way do I go?
Oh, wait.
Yeah.
He's still also... He's still weak too.
So I don't have to worry.
I like how his buddy is just watching.
He's just like...
All right.
Let's wait for him to get beat up before I go in.
Nice.
Absorb.
Oh, hey.
This guy's not flesh.
I mean, technically.
Oh, he's just...
What is he?
What the fuck is... Whoa!
What are you...
Whoa!
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
From fleshy human to whatever this guy was.
What a fucking jump skill.
Oh my god.
The skill gap between these two is actually crazy.
Oh, please you.
Please you.
I'm going to bring the baby.
I'm bringing the baby.
Okay.
That's not...
Oh, the baby did it.
Yay.
That's not what I wanted, but it worked.
It worked.
Thank god.
Thank god it worked.
Wait, but why?
What was he guarding?
Oh, he was guarding this.
Thank you, baby.
Wait, but there's something over here.
I think it can go up, right?
Let me double check.
I thought I could.
Can I?
No.
It was just one way.
Nice.
Yeah, that snake compared to the fleshy human.
Jeez.
The damage.
Alright.
Up we go.
Up the mountain we go.
What?
There's another human.
Look at him just walk down the stairs.
It's so sad.
I mean...
After fighting so many quads, just seeing these people.
What the fuck?
That's a tiger snake.
A tiger and a snake fucked and made that.
Holy shit.
What a freak.
You're a freak.
Oh my god.
Look at you.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
I did not mean that.
I meant that.
Look at you.
Which one's the mom and which one's the dad?
I have so many questions.
I feel like the mom had to be the tiger.
There's no way.
It's like some Kung Fu Panda shit.
Oh my god.
I'm so sorry.
Jesus.
He kept locking me in the corner.
I'm sorry.
Sorry for calling you a freak.
Oh my god.
Look at him.
He has like a snake tongue too.
Nice.
The throw.
The throw he threw at me.
That's insane.
The snake sheriff.
A head so large.
A tail so thin.
Seven foot long.
With tiger stripes.
Does it say how there was a tiger with a strong desire for the dad?
Oh, it tells how his dad met his mom.
At first, the warrior mastered a stainer for being a mere tiger.
Unlike his other disciple and refused to see him.
Oh my god.
He hates his master hated tigers.
What does it say where he bangs the snake?
The tiger...
Oh!
He became a snake!
Through Taoist practice!
After some time he could no longer speak.
Oh, because he trained so hard that he became a snake tiger.
Yeah.
He got cursed.
He got cursed into becoming the freak he is.
That's sadder.
That's sadder than...
Wait, was this the right way?
Because he wasn't because of an illegal affair between a snake and a tiger.
He just got cursed to be like that.
He got cursed.
Because his master doesn't want to train a tiger.
Why wouldn't you?
That's so cool!
That fucking tiger was like I wanna be like...
I wanna be like these...
Like these guys are so weak too!
Like the master trained like weak ass fucking...
fucking soul Taoist people.
Like look at them!
They're so weak!
I don't wanna train a tiger!
Alright.
Up we go.
He wasn't a cat person.
He made some weak ass soldiers.
That's for sure.
These are like flesh bodies.
I can kill this guy in five seconds.
Watch this.
One, two...
Sorry.
Count stop.
Two, three, four...
Okay, there you go.
See?
Less than five.
The count only starts when I start hitting.
When they hit back, we stop the count.
Why are you so weak?
Okay.
Grab some...
Let me stop.
How many tigers wanted to be religious?
It's like...
Because there's so many!
How many did you curse?
Like...
I don't understand.
I thought it was just one.
But apparently there's two at least.
He ate it so...
Like...
That wasn't even the first tiger he cursed?
He just didn't like tigers.
How did he curse more than one tiger?
Wait.
Did he curse this guy too?
Did he make them worms?
And was like...
Would you love me if I stole a worm?
He's a tiger hater.
What
the fuck?
He cursed him too?
He...
He made him into worms!
Not only did he curse regular tigers...
He also made people...
Who is this master?
Am I going to beat the shit out of him?
Am I going to beat up this master?
He's a hater.
He just hates everything.
It's this way.
Okay.
You're all cursed.
But yet they're stronger than the regular guys.
Let's go.
This master has impossible standards.
Would the town still love me if I was a worm?
Oh fuck!
Bro, that's cheap.
The master didn't teach you that.
The master doesn't want that.
The master doesn't like cheap shit.
Yeah.
Up we go.
What are you doing?
Guarding?
Why are you guarding my shrine?
Bro, this is my shrine.
That's right.
My shrine.
Human jumpscare.
A man!
Okay, rest.
Alright.
Oh, do I have new stuff?
I do!
What do I have?
Take a sip without- Oh!
Okay.
Increases damage reduction.
Okay, we'll get that.
I like that more.
Wait, what did I get?
Increases damage reduction.
Grants a considerable chance to take a sip without consuming gourd.
Okay, wait.
36% more increases movement speed.
36% of maximum health.
I like the mana more.
Uh, can I rest?
Yeah, I did.
Yeah, I did rest.
Okay.
Oh my god, no!
An open area!
This is my worst nightmare!
A non-linear path!
Oh no!
My worst nightmare!
Alright.
I guess I'll go this way.
Oh, the birds are nice, people.
Is there- No, that doesn't go anywhere.
Oh, it's him!
It's the worm guy!
Oh, okay, goodbye.
I guess you don't care.
The real bot- Oh, wait!
You tricked me!
Like, look at them!
They're stronger as worms than regular people!
Well, they have more HP.
I wouldn't say stronger.
They have more HP as regular- as worm- as worm men.
Oh, shit!
And they have poison, too!
Nice, alright.
It's alright if I'm poisoned.
It's okay.
What the fuck?
Okay, this guy- Is this master or whatever?
He really loves poisoning his people.
And turning them into worms.
The worm men.
Would you love your disciples if they were worms, guys?
Alright, nice.
Whoa!
Oh my god, please don't tell me I'm gonna fall!
Please!
Oh my god, no!
Not the regular humans!
I- I died to the flesh bags!
I have never died to humans!
Oh no, I can't believe I died to the regular humans!
My reputation is gone!
Okay, it'll never happen again.
I learned my lesson.
It'll never happen again.
Okay, I'll freeze this guy.
Freeze.
These guys are so annoying, though.
I need to get rid of him.
Because of their poison shit.
Oh, it's a meditation!
I don't understand why he hates tigers.
I mean, if my disciple is a fucking tiger, like, why would you say no?
Like, it's a fucking tiger.
Come on!
Do you know how strong fucking tigers are?
A tiger is like ten men.
Like, why did he curse him?
He's so cool!
Exactly!
Imagine seeing a tiger!
Like, it's like Kung Fu Panda!
Has this master not watched Kung Fu Panda?
Like, has he not watched Kung Fu Panda?
I can't believe it!
Does he not know?
Alright, let's see.
We're gonna...
The master hates Kung Fu Panda.
Oh yeah, I wanted a critical hit.
Uh, I'll go this way.
Okay, he'll never happen again.
I told you, never again I learned my lesson.
Guys, don't you know Kung Fu Panda?
Kung Fu Panda was based off a book that was released at the same time as Journey to the West.
It was also called Kung Fu Panda.
You think people would just spread misinformation like that on the internet?
Yeah!
It was based off a book that was written around the same time Journey to the West was written.
No, it was actually Journey to the...
Journey to the West was based off of the ye olde Kung Fu Panda book.
I'm sure that is Kung Fu true.
What is that?
Hey guys.
Oh!
Oh, okay.
Sorry.
I just wanted to... Oh, sorry.
Maybe I should...
I have reinforcements too.
Meet my disciples.
That's fucking right.
That's right.
I also have disciples too, guys.
That's fucking right.
That's right!
Oh shit!
Oh, okay.
Yeah, I got me some disciples too.
Not just...
Not just you and my...
If they were tigers, I'd let them be a disciple as well.
Go home, monkey army.
Oh, Jesus Christ.
I took so much damage there.
Alright.
Yellow dragon time.
What the fuck?
Okay, still yellow dragon time.
Still okay.
Still yellow... Okay.
Okay, still yellow dragon time.
Like...
It's never stopped.
It's never stopped yellow dragon time.
Wait.
Why am I here?
Wait, he can carry?
That's legal.
You're not even real.
Guys, oh no.
Oh no.
Wait, where did he come from?
Wait, why am I slowed?
Oh, God.
Okay.
What the fuck?
How is he allowed to do that?
How the...
Boy, how is he allowed to do that?
That's... what?
Ow!
Not fair!
What the fuck?
He's allowed to dodge?
Okay.
Oh, he killed his own guy.
That's good.
That's actually really good for me.
That's fucking right.
Can't block this.
That's fucking...
You don't need a block.
Okay.
And that's okay.
I'm just gonna hydrate again.
Gonna keep hydrating.
Alright.
Okay, this guy is strong.
This... Wow!
This guy is very strong, guys.
This... Oh, my God.
I...
Okay.
What are your patterns?
Like... What the fuck?
Holy shit!
He's not even human!
Okay.
Oh, God.
Knocked him.
No, I was trying to use freeze, but I messed up.
You're not even human!
Nice.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
I have...
Dragon time.
That's fucking right.
Oh, that's okay.
Dragon time.
The slowest dragon mode ever.
Yeah!
We did it!
Alright.
Commander Beetle.
When faced with traps, one must pass the test.
When fortune smells...
Oh, there he is.
Look at his tiny head.
Nice.
We did it.
Oh!
It's a summon, too!
Nice!
I like that.
This is for the tiger.
This is for all the tigers!
You said no!
Alright.
Commander Beetle.
Nice.
There's a chest here, too.
What did I get?
Oh!
A tablet.
Tablet of the Three Supremes.
Curious.
No idea what that is, but I assume it's helpful.
Alright.
Now that we killed the master, they have nobody else to follow.
Your master is dead now, sir.
He's dead.
Like, what are you still doing here?
He's literally dead.
There's no reason to be here anymore.
That's not the master?
What the fuck?
Who the fuck was he?
Wait!
If he's not the master, then what was he doing?
Why was he commanding them?
That's all...
Oh, so the master doesn't give a fuck about beetles?
Like, he was uglier than a tiger!
But he was...
He was uglier than a tiger!
What's wrong with tigers?
I don't understand!
I don't understand.
Like...
That's too far.
He's the guy that was racist to tigers!
And I'm going too far!
I wasn't racist to tigers!
I just killed him!
But that doesn't mean I'm racist!
He started it!
What's wrong with beetles?
I don't know what's wrong with tigers!
Beetleman is beautiful!
Yeah, he started it and I ended it!
Circle of life, baby!
Alright, let's go!
Oh, is there anything here?
Oh, there's a tunnel here!
Oh, there's more worms!
Guys, I'm starting to think the master isn't a fucking human.
I'm starting...
Guys!
I think the master is a fucking bug!
I don't know, guys.
I'm starting to get a feeling...
That there's a pattern here.
Alright...
Oh...
Envy!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Beetle also human!
Master turned him into a beetle!
Beetle longed for death and thank you when he died!
Oh, see!
Look, I did a good thing!
I'm not a monster!
They asked for it!
Another area here...
Secret?
No, it's not secret.
Not secret?
Alright...
Up we go!
Oh, no!
It's not linear!
People when they see open world will be like...
Yay, open world!
Me, when I see an open world...
Where do I...
No, no...
Where do I go?
Guys, you don't understand.
Okay, this way.
Alright...
Sorry, my brain...
I saw the non-linear pathway...
And then my brain just...
I just didn't know what to do.
It wasn't linear.
So I got confused.
Alright, oh, this way?
This first?
Okay.
That's right side, right?
Oh, hey, another tiger!
Jesus, there's so many tigers.
I really hated the tigers.
Why did so many of them wanted to be disciples?
Okay, I'm just gonna make sure there's like nothing here.
Oh, there's a meditation!
Let's just get rid of these guys then.
Boop!
This way.
Alright.
Let's meditate.
Can I meditate?
Wow!
Alright.
Let's get rid of it.
Please!
Please don't kill me!
I can't!
I don't know the meditation phrase!
I swear if I like get back in it, I die!
I lose like half my life!
Please!
Time out of meditation!
Wait, where did it go?
What?
Please!
Where did they go?
Oh my god, my HP.
I think I actually did lose HP from them beating the shit out of me.
I...
Okay.
Alright, it's fine.
We're okay.
Oh shit.
There's so many worms!
Oh my god!
Let me go!
Jesus Christ!
There's so many!
Okay, we gotta do this now.
Okay, nice.
Oh...
Yeah, I'm pretty sure like when I meditated, it healed back the HP they did to me.
Oh, it's the tiger!
Stop looking around.
I'm going in.
Go fork my monkeys!
Go fork!
It's time to beat up a tiger!
Monkeys?
Okay, you came here after I started.
Okay.
That's fine.
That's okay.
Sorry.
My monkeys got this.
I believe in the power of monkey.
Oh my god.
Alright, all my monkeys are dead, but that's okay.
Because what is he gonna do?
Oh, he's gonna do that!
He's gonna do that!
What is he gonna do?
Now.
I spent all my resources on this one tiger.
Monkeys were lost.
That's fine.
It was worth it.
It was so worth it.
It was a very strong tiger!
Monkeys needed a map.
The monkeys reflected me and I was also lost.
So then they were also lost too.
It's understandable, you know?
Like we were both...
We were both lost.
Oh hey, it's him!
It's him!
It's the guy that Yellow Lone possessed.
I'm gonna steal this first before I talk to you.
That was inspirational.
Oh!
Look, she gave up everything for him!
For love!
And for... oh shit, sorry.
My phone.
My phone charger wasn't charging.
Is it charging now?
I'm gonna be loading right now.
No, it's not charging.
Can't tell.
Is it?
Okay, I think it is.
I think it's charging now.
Sorry!
I might need a new charger.
I might need a new cable.
I'm gonna grab... oh.
Get rid of this worm first.
That's why I was loading.
I had... I didn't have battery left.
Alright.
Nice.
Okay, I just wanna grab this.
The rest of you don't matter.
Alright, nice.
I'll just head off.
Bye guys!
Bye!
Go do your worm things here.
Alright, up we go.
This is a surprisingly long chapter.
I thought chapter 3 was long, but this one is like...
longer.
But I like this chapter more than... I definitely like this chapter more than the snow chapter.
The snow chapter fucking sucked.
I can navigate this much better.
That's for sure.
I definitely feel like I can navigate this better.
I like this chapter more.
I like the story more too for this one.
Versus the chapter 3.
Alright, here we go.
Oh, chapter 5 is more fun overall.
I'm chapter 4, right?
Wait, which chapter am I on?
I...
Wait a minute.
Guys, which chapter am I on?
Oh, I'm on 4.
Okay, I was like...
Wait, am I on chapter 5?
So I got...
I got confused.
Okay, this is 4.
I thought I was on 4.
Why did they bring up 5?
Guys, which one is optional?
Right or left?
Chat, which one...
Which one is the optional one?
Optional errors to the right?
Okay, we go right side.
Worm guy.
Alright, get rid of the worm guy first.
Get out of here.
Oh, get left first for the shrine?
Okay, I want to steal his stuff first.
I want to steal his stuff and then I'll go left.
Alright, nice.
Mine now.
Yoink.
There's a shrine.
There's a shrine here?
Okay.
I'm going to kill you first.
And then your buddy can watch because apparently he likes that.
Alright, there you go.
He's dead now.
You can come...
Oh shit, there's a tiger!
There's another one?
Oh my god.
Okay, we'll just leave him there.
Alright.
Bro, he cursed so many ti- He could have had a tiger army!
He literally could have had a tiger army!
Okay, rest.
Alright, let's go.
Can't believe it!
I can't believe he actually ditched the tigers!
He could have had it all!
Mad made it his mission to bully the tigers.
This is the year of the worm.
Apparently.
Okay, I'm going to recharge.
Reload!
Okay, I didn't expect the slash there.
Look at him!
He's so clumsy too!
He like fell over!
After like one fucking slash.
What a clumsy worm.
Alright, let's get this guy out of the way.
Get out of here.
Guys, I didn't miss any loot.
It was...
I bet you it was fucking iron leaves again.
I have like 200 million iron leaves.
Guys, I don't need more.
Guys, I don't need more iron leaves.
I guess I have too many iron leaves.
We don't need more.
Like I don't need more I'm not doing anything.
Alright.
Let's see.
Oh no.
Multiple choice.
I assume left side is optional?
It looks like an optional area.
Oh no.
Which was the optional area?
Which...
Oh, it's a boss?
Okay, I'll go for the boss.
Both were optional.
The other route is...
Okay.
We'll go this way.
Just too many optional areas.
Alright, this looks like a boss fight.
The fuck is...
Oh, is that the...
Wait, was that the child I forced to be burned?
Yeah!
That's him!
What's wrong with that?
You're alive because of me.
You were stuck... Oh, fuck!
I'm so sorry.
I guess he didn't want to be alive.
I don't fucking know.
Like...
Like, he realized being alive fucks being...
Now he has to pay taxes and he hates it.
He's like, how dare you!
Now I have to pay my taxes!
Now I have to get a job!
Life is suffering.
I have to look into housing!
And insurance!
And credit score!
Because of you!
I never asked to be born!
My life!
Ru-luan fei-sheng!
Wu-yong-de zhi-jie-chi-la!
Oh, I took all his limbs off.
Shi-wo shang-la-nei lao-dao-shi-de-dang!
Gang-cai-de du-dao!
Don't make me... Please don't make me get the job.
I'm the god of the gods.
I am a fair fighter.
I'm a dragon lady now.
What the fuck he took away?
What?!
He took away my abilities!
That's fucked.
He actually took away my stuff.
Like that's so illegal.
That should be illegal!
And he healed?!
How dare you!
I'm the main character!
How could you just heal like that?
Just like what I'm gonna do.
Just because I took your arms you get to heal?
Like, what?!
Alright.
It's not fair.
I should not be able to heal if I took away his arms.
Like...
Like we all have to struggle here.
Oh my god.
Even though he's buff he still fights like a baby.
Like...
Bro thinks he's the protagonist.
Fine, Nino.
I already had Nino.
Oh I did it!
Oh that was easy.
Alright.
Go!
What happens?
Woah!
It's so beautiful!
What
is this place?
What is this place?
Obsession.
A remnant of worldly ties transforms the unfinished aspirations into spaces.
Secret in purple cloud.
What use are eight arms against twenty strikes of my staff?
True.
Secret tunnel.
The best looking area in the game.
Oh no, my frames.
Not the best looking area in all I can think about is...
No, no, my frames.
Oh no, there's so many leaves.
There's so...
Look at all these physics!
Oh no, the foliage!
The foliage!
The leaves!
Oh there's the mountain!
That's not a cloud.
That's literally like vines in the sky.
Who's crying?
Hello?
Are you okay, lady?
Oh, it's a snake!
A kind passerby will help you find your remains?
Well, that's not me.
Imagine if I just walk up, she's like crying, and I'm just like walk away.
Why are you crying?
Little Master.
I'm a little lost.
I was originally from the Wei Dynasty.
I came here to see my father.
Not my problem.
My husband and I lived in the manor on the top of the mountain.
What happened to your husband?
One day, I don't know where I got the poison from.
I had to fight for it.
The manor is full of dead people.
Oh, you're the lone survivor?
Why didn't you slither away?
The scorpion way.
Oh!
That's what happened.
Wait, I have a guy that's really lonely, you know?
And like, you have zero limbs, too.
So like, it'd be a nice change of pace.
You know, from eight limbs to zero?
Like, oh my god.
That would be wild.
And like, you have no kids, right?
It's like, how many kids do you have?
You don't seem to have any children.
Alright, off we go.
I'm asking for a friend.
Bro, he's heartbroken, man.
He got tricked into paying for a million children's child support.
Alright,
here we go.
I thought he had one child, but no.
It was more than the one child.
Oh, is that him?
Who the fuck is that?
Oh, that's a tree!
Good.
Time to beat up a tree.
It's time.
Time to beat up a fucking tree, guys.
This is what I've been wanting to do for a long time.
Trees had it too good for two's eyes.
These goddamn trees.
I don't need oxygen.
I don't need O2.
That's fucking right.
Carbon dioxide.
No, donkey!
Don't spread the carbon dioxide!
There he goes.
So evil.
Absorb.
I'm gonna expel all the carbon dioxide now.
We're dying.
Alright, nice.
Nice.
I'm gonna kill the tree.
She has become the monster.
Get her!
She's breathing!
Wait, there's another shrine?
Oh my god, how many shrines are there?
Take up the planet.
How bad can I be?
I'm destroying necessarily.
Alright, I'll get this shrine real quick.
Okay.
A tree had it coming.
Oh my god, the foliage.
The leaf physics!
My friends!
This place is too beautiful!
It's too beautiful, guys!
This place!
Where do I go?
Okay.
It's still a person, so like, he's gonna be easy to kill.
I thought I was supposed to deal with a scorpion king.
Why are there people?
Like, why are there people here?
I don't understand.
I thought I was supposed to be dealing with, like, bugs.
But the beauty, it burns!
Oh my god, the tree fucking stabbed me!
What the fuck?
It's cause I killed its leader.
It stabbed me.
Here we go.
Oh, I'll crab this, though.
Just in case.
Got the tree pearl.
Who's that?
Oh, is that the scorpion?
Oh, I already found him!
Go, go, go.
Are you depressed?
Look, you can just ask somebody if they're depressed.
I mean, look at him.
He's drinking on the roof.
Get down here!
Break your jars!
That's fucking...
Oh my god, wait.
He actually gets mad.
I didn't think he actually gets mad.
You chose the root.
Yeah, that's right.
That's fucking right!
I broke your jar.
What you gonna do about that?
Shit!
Okay.
I literally started to see my life flash before me there.
Holy shit!
Okay, okay.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Okay, now I know why it's called a depth stinger.
That makes more sense now.
Uh, don't mess with this.
Okay, now I know why it was called that.
How did I get there?
I don't even remember.
Oh, it's this way.
I was like, I don't even remember how I got there.
Oh my god.
Okay, it's this way.
Oh, I missed this.
He's up the stairs.
You don't need to go.
I'm gonna do it.
You can't stop me.
I walked a long way.
Oh, the stairs leads there.
Oh!
That's fucking right now!
That's fucking right now I know what I'm doing.
Oh, god.
Oh!
Guys, this depth stinger is a little scary, guys.
Holy fuck!
Okay.
Okay, he's a little tanky, guys.
He's pretty tanky.
I just... What the fuck?
Holy shit!
Now I know why they call it the depth stinger.
Okay, I'm gonna use the two to heal.
Like, right now.
Oh my god, he's so fucking tanky.
That's actually crazy.
Whoa!
What?
Bro, I just broke a couple of jars.
I don't understand!
Whoa!
Oh my
god!
Okay.
He does not like that!
Guys, this guy is... This guy is pretty freaky.
Not gonna lie.
What the fuck?
Okay.
What?
Stop it!
Oh my god!
This guy is so fucking tanky!
The poison actually got me!
Let me try the thrust dance.
Jesus Christ!
This guy... Oh wait, this was like, literally the easy path to him.
That's awkward.
Alright, I'm getting over.
I'm heading over.
I wanna get in on that action.
That's fucking right.
Oh my god!
God!
He does so much damage!
There's no way I'm underleveled!
There's no way!
I refuse to!
Please, I don't wanna level up!
Okay.
Nice.
Jesus Christ!
Like...
Oh my god!
He does so much!
It's actually insane how much...
It's actually insane!
I...
Oh!
Oh fuck!
Holy shit!
Okay.
That's scary.
That's actually scary.
Please!
Ah!
Oh my god!
Have fucking mercy!
Am I underleveled?
Oh my!
There's no way!
Oh my god, I need heal.
I need... I need a heal.
He's so tanky!
Boom!
Oh!
Maybe I just don't know his combos!
Maybe I just don't know his combos yet!
Maybe that's it!
Okay, that's... this is it.
I'm grabbing friends.
You go gattle that, bro.
You guys go...
I swear to god, if my monkeys die, I... Monkeys, please!
He's right there, monkeys!
Please!
I need you!
Oh!
Thank god!
Okay!
My one monkey now!
Alright!
I'm by myself after all that!
Okay!
Holy shit!
Oh my god, I need a heal.
I have two heals left.
Oh god!
Oh my god!
Okay!
Come on!
My only hope!
Come on yellow truck!
Get you off your feet!
I don't know that help, but...
What the fuck!
Okay.
I got slowed.
No.
No!
Please!
I did a joke!
Oh my god!
I'm almost like...
Oh thank fucking god!
I was so close!
I'm actually 1 HP!
Oh my god!
Thank god!
We actually did it!
Oh that was way too close!
That was way too close!
I almost choked.
Oh I almost choked and got relatable.
Okay we can craft armor too.
Thank god.
It's not even better armor!
It's not even better!
That's fine.
We can rest.
Oh my god.
Alright time to tell the snake lady that...
Wait.
Alright so I killed him.
Now this is where we let her know this boss is skippable and missable the whole time but he's fun right?
Just below yellow lone...
Wait but I killed him in 2 tries.
John what do you mean?
I killed him in 2 tries!
Thank you for the super chat content!
Thank you!
Oh 3 tries.
Okay.
Where's the chest?
I guess that's why he's just below.
Right?
Alright.
This is it.
Chest time.
Alright.
Holy shit we got rid of him.
I have to find her remains right?
The...
husband remains?
Right?
Or can I just talk to the snake now?
I can't believe you.
This was an intervention guys.
Alright let's see.
Wait where's this?
Mal was just depressed.
I beat him.
He was just trying to drink.
I beat up an alcoholic while he was just trying to be depressed.
Oh no.
Guys please don't cancel me on twitter.
Like I didn't.
No.
Guys I didn't mean to beat up a depressed person.
Like he committed war crimes guys.
It doesn't exempt him.
He still committed war crimes.
Chat.
You're defending a war criminal.
Alright let's see.
So lost.
Will I ever not be lost?
Oh there's another thing.
Oh there's a shrine here.
Alright.
I gotta go this way.
Hello.
Your friend's dead.
I love how they.
I love how like one.
The other guy just watches his friend get beat up.
Every time.
I assume I crossed this bridge.
Alright.
Rest time.
I guess I go this way.
There's like another pathway up here.
Which I assumed.
There's so many optional areas.
Which is the correct optional.
I hate being forced to make decisions.
It's so difficult.
I'm so bad at making decisions.
I'm trying to beat up a tree again.
I beat up his like his dad.
So like it's fine.
I can do it again.
Oh god.
Why are they so tanky?
Oh yeah.
I don't have energy.
That's why.
I realized like.
I have zero stamina.
He's so tall.
I was looking up at his legs.
Doki his eyes are up there.
Yeah we go this way.
Cause there's a.
There's like a path up here.
I think.
Yeah.
Nice absorb.
If you do your.
croquis intro.
You get bonus output in your monkey.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh hey a bridge.
Is this optional?
This has to be an optional area.
There's no way.
Thank you for your.
Very first super chat too.
Please.
Oh my god.
I'm fucking gonna.
I'm gonna go nuclear.
I'm gonna.
Alright.
Where am I?
We'll turn this car around.
I swear to fucking god.
Is this way?
Oh meditation.
Oh.
Meditation time.
Oh my god.
I can't.
I'm meditating so hard.
That my friend.
It's just too beautiful.
This place is too beautiful.
It's too beautiful.
Like.
This is why I'm killing all the trees.
So I can make it less beautiful.
I'm just trying.
Trying to make it less beautiful guy.
Meditate down to 20 frames.
Okay.
Oh, I can.
Are we going to upgrade?
Alright, let's see.
I guess I can put more into... I want to get more in critical hit.
Yeah.
What can I upgrade?
Damage reduction during light attack?
Fuck yeah, let's go.
Where do I go?
I guess down?
What goes down?
Let's go up.
Alright, down we go.
Oh, I guess that was like an optional area for the meditation.
Okay, now I don't know where I am anymore.
Do I ever know?
No, now I don't know where I am.
Oh, left!
Okay, I know.
I recognize that tree.
I recognize that temple.
Left.
And then we go right and then there's other stuff.
Tommy!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I've been feeling down lately.
I just want to say thanks for your streams.
Never fails to brighten my day.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm glad to brighten your day today with Wukong.
I do.
When you guys get super annoyed by video games giving you instructions and tips, they're doing it for me.
They're Doki-proofing the game.
I'm the reason why games are like that.
You're welcome.
It was you!
I am the target audience.
The reason for the yellow paint.
Oh, hey.
Is he playing music?
Hello!
A music player can't be a bad guy, right?
Yeah!
I knew it!
Is this...
Is this Drupal guy?
Or the dad?
Or the husband?
Is that the dead husband?
My fellow disciple is hungry for...
Wait!
Are you the...
Are you the master?
No.
Okay, he's just a random guy.
Okay, you were just nobody.
They're eggs on...
Ah!
I'm going to find a way to solve this problem.
Little gentleman, do you have any senior brothers?
No, no.
I think they like to play around in the manor.
Can you see around?
So I just need to...
I just need to bring him here.
I'm giving him the eggs.
What are you gonna do with the eggs?
Bro, are you a freak?
What the fuck are you gonna do with... bro, that's fucking weird, bro.
Bro, are you gonna eat it?
Like, what the fuck are you gonna do with those eggs?
That's fucking weird, man.
Bro, that's fucking weird.
What I'm saying is that, that's fucking weird.
Like, what is he gonna do with those eggs?
Alright, nice.
I got some gold.
I robbed this man's wallet.
Okay, chest time.
Nice.
See guys, this is why I don't need iron cold leaves.
I got more iron cold leaves again.
Okay, I guess I'll harvest this for now.
Okay.
Go up.
Up I go.
Hello?
Hello.
I thought, I thought the snake, the snake said there's gonna be like, bugs.
It's literally just people.
Unless people were the real bugs all along.
Okay.
Oh no.
There's forward, left, I'm gonna go right.
I'm gonna go right.
This way.
This looks like the village from earlier.
From the beginning.
With the bridge?
It looks so similar.
Unless it is.
Look for it.
Oh.
Wait, it's the same.
It's like, looks so similar.
Oh, there's a killer.
Oh my god, am I getting it?
What is this?
Oh, there's spiders.
Whoa!
Okay, we gotta get rid of the spider guy.
Wait, do you have eggs inside you?
Bro, do you have some eggs?
Bro, he has no eggs!
Where the fuck are your eggs?
Bro, I was given a mission!
Oh, only the humans?
Oh, okay, I should go back then.
I'll go back.
I thought the spiders had them too, cause they're already...
I guess cause the eggs haven't hatched inside them.
Alright, bro, it's harvest time.
It's harvest season.
Wait, how do I get across?
Okay, I'll just go left.
I thought I could go front, but I guess not.
Is there anything here?
Bro, do you have eggs inside you?
Bro, can I...
Can I see?
I gotta know.
You got them eggs inside you?
He doesn't have no eggs!
Where the fuck are the eggs?
How am I supposed to harvest them?
Okay, you can't just ask him if he got eggs inside him.
Oh, shit!
Shit!
Okay, is that...
Oh my god, are you fucking kidding me?
Oh no, I think I might die from... I think I might die from the poison.
I'm just gonna get this guy out of the way.
Can't believe it!
A chest in the middle and it was a trap all along?
Could they?
There's no integrity anymore.
Nice, more gold.
Where is the integrity?
Alright, this way.
Is there anything here?
So many webs.
Oh!
Oh, there's a shrine!
There's a shrine near me!
Nice!
Yo, did you fuck a spider and she laid eggs in you?
Like...
Is this T... Is that TMI?
Bro, I don't know if it's TMI, but...
Alright, maybe he has them.
Bro, do you got eggs?
You?
No!
All they have is willpower!
What am I gonna do with willpower?
Oh, is that up?
Okay, don't go up.
Okay, I go down.
I guess that's up.
Is this also up?
I don't think this counts, right?
Alright, what about you?
Sir, do you have any?
God damn it, they only have willpower!
What am I gonna do with willpower?
Okay, nice.
I have to get rid of the spider too.
Still no eggs!
Bro, that man lies to me!
He's like, my men, they're gonna have some eggs in them.
Fucking liar!
They're eggless!
That means they didn't get lucky!
They didn't get lucky, those poor men!
Like, what's the point of letting the spiders here if they didn't get so lucky?
Thank you!
The fate...
The fuck?
What?
No spider?
No spider wife?
Those poor guys.
Didn't even score a spider wife.
That already farmed?
Didn't even...
Maybe I got it already and I didn't notice.
No, you guys would have yelled at me if I did.
You guys would 100% yell at me and be like, you already got it, Toki!
Why are you still farming?
Okay, reload.
Okay, maybe...
Do I go back up here?
Can I go up here?
Wait, not up here.
I'm quite lost in this confined area.
Here.
Am I allowed to go up here?
Is there anything here?
Whoa!
That scared me.
Oh my god!
Okay!
Oh, my camera!
My camera fucked up!
Will.
So willpower!
Did none of you get lucky?
Are you all eggless?
That's sad, bro.
That's so sad.
It's complete RNG, bro.
Okay, that says a lot about me.
That says a lot about me.
It's complete RNG.
Holy shit.
Why?
Alright.
Still none.
Still no egg.
Eggless behavior.
I guess...
Oh my god, time to rest again.
They were not chosen.
They sadly didn't get chosen by the one million spider women.
I think the best part is that there was not...
That granny had so many kids.
And I still haven't found a single one!
I don't understand!
How is that possible?
There's so many!
Okay.
I'll just find these same three people over and over again till I find one.
I can't be bothered.
I can't!
Alright.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Here we go.
Off we go.
You know what?
Since I'm gonna be here for a bit.
Is it overkill?
Yes.
But like you don't understand, I'm desperate here right now.
I'm so desperate.
Is that it?
No, it's just level up.
What am I gonna do with a level up?
What am I gonna do?
Still will.
It's still willpower.
Why did they not impregnate these men?
No!
Okay.
Alright.
Here we go.
There we go.
Alright.
Is that it?
Violent hell?
Is that what?
There it is!
He got chosen!
Congratulations!
You got chosen!
Oh my god.
Congratulations.
You got impregnated.
Oh my god.
Deadpool, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You got impregnated.
Thank fucking god.
Oh my god.
Thank god.
Good for him.
Alright.
Nice.
Here we go.
I got the egg.
It wasn't even called an egg.
It was called Violent Hell.
I guess because her name is Violet.
Oh!
I guess because she was living up with ghosts, I had to go back.
I had to go back to Buddha Temple.
What?
Is he evil?
Wait!
What?
Wait, you're evil?
But I gave you the egg!
Yeah!
Why are you evil?
I gave you what you wanted!
I know what I mean!
Wow!
The guy that looked evil was actually evil!
He did ask nicely, Doki.
I can't believe...
That's why he's gonna break stereotypes, guys!
I thought he was gonna break the stereotype.
I was like, the man that looks evil cannot possibly be evil.
That's shocking.
Always judge a book by its cover.
I was trying to not judge a book by its cover!
I was trying to be open-minded here!
I wanted to be open-minded!
Wait, what?
Did my mouse die?
Sorry!
I didn't move because I was like, why couldn't I hit?
I thought my mouse died.
So I looked at him.
Wait, phase two?
Metamorphosis?
Did she just...
How did...
Oh, shit!
Would you love me if I was a worm?
Oh, no!
No, not the worm question!
Not the worm question!
No!
Now he becomes worm.
He's gonna...
What the fuck is he doing?
That's what he's doing!
Okay, I was so confused there.
I was like, what is that?
Oh, no.
He's asking the question.
Guys, what do I say?
What do I say, guys?
I don't know.
Like, look at him.
Oh, god.
Whoa!
Okay, I'm gonna heal for real now.
Nice.
Alright.
Oh, my god.
Get away from me.
Alright, here you go.
He's so lovable.
Toki, I don't understand.
Why won't you love him if he was a worm?
Guys, he's a fucking worm!
Alright.
Alright, no way he's gonna be able to get...
Okay, never mind.
He is.
Alright, there you go.
And he chose it.
It's not like some magic power fucking made him a worm.
Oh.
That's it?
He just turns back to normal?
Hello, is this your...
Who's this guy, snake lady?
What?
Hmph.
These ordinary people don't know what they're doing.
Oh, god!
She's...
She's beautiful.
Still would.
She's got the gamer neck.
Oh
my god.
My staff is so fucking disgusting.
I just realized what it is.
Transform into a worm.
Why?
Guys!
We can do it!
Let me go...
Oh my god.
Okay.
We can finally be our true selves, guys.
We can finally be our true selves.
Oh my god.
Okay.
That's funny.
Can I cultivate this?
Oh my god, I can.
Upgrade big baby before I do this.
Alright, guys.
Just for one moment, I'll do it for you.
Dragons.
Would you love me if I become a...
Oh god, I'm so fucking ugly.
Would you love me if I become a worm?
Tell me I'm beautiful dragons.
Tell me.
Please.
Oh my god.
That's how I fucking get out of world guide.
That's actually pretty disgusting.
I'm not gonna lie.
That's how I fucking get out of worm form too.
Alright, let's see.
We gotta go to the peak.
That's good knowing unsubscribe.
Alright, nice.
Let's go.
Up I go.
I still... I'll listen to your streams.
Oh.
What's this?
Oh my god.
Is that John Toomer?
What the fuck is that?
Oh!
Oh my god.
It's pulsating.
That's an egg?
Is that another child from Chupacay?
Oh god.
Who did she fuck?
The Dusk Veil.
What the fuck did you bang?
Like what?
Oh my god.
What is he?
How does he have low HP already?
Wait.
How does he have...
How did he start with half HP?
Did she bang a chicken?
Like...
Did he get fall damage?
Okay, that's pretty funny.
He literally got fall damage.
I was like, wait a minute.
I did not do that.
You boy.
Oh my god.
She fucked a chicken.
Sorry.
What's wrong with her?
Bro.
Bro, she went...
Bro, that breakup was hard on her.
Not gonna lie.
I think...
I think the breakup with Pixie was really hard on her.
Like, she got drunk and she got busy.
She got...
She got real busy.
The breakup did not do so well.
No!
Are you fucking... I hate you.
I hate you so much.
I hate you.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Please.
Okay.
Wait, what?
Oh, I did not mean to drink, but that's alright, I guess.
That's okay, I guess.
Oh, Jesus Christ.
Okay.
Nice.
Freeze.
Get the legs!
Whoa!
Shit!
Okay.
That's fine.
Oh my god, alright.
It's fine.
We're fine.
We're okay.
Look, we all had those types of phases.
I know a breakup was hard for you.
Okay.
Nice.
Just one more hit.
Whoa!
What?
Okay, we still did it.
Oh no, not phase two.
Oh, this looks like a phase two.
This looks like...
There was no name.
I killed him, but no name showed up.
Second phase.
The Blood Moon?
Oh no.
It's never good when there's a Blood Moon.
Alright.
Blood Moon taught me anything.
When the moon is red.
When he healed, he got a sword!
What the fuck?
Who gave the chicken a sword?
Like...
No!
I don't get the fall damage!
What the fuck?
Holy shit!
That's absolutely fucking insane damage!
Oh my god!
The baby has a knife now!
That shit one shot!
I got shredded.
Oh my god, the giant chicken still got me.
I got chicken.
No!
Are you serious?
Oh wait, what?
How come he shows up with...
Oh my god.
Only happens to Doki.
Oh, okay.
Like, I'll take that.
Okay.
I mean, that's good.
That's good.
He also fucked up too.
Like, we fucked up together.
That's good.
Like, he was like, that's embarrassing.
But then he was like, you know what, let's let's both be a little embarrassing together.
I really appreciate that chicken.
He doesn't know how to fly yet.
Yeah.
Oh, I can see underneath him.
Is he a boy or a girl?
We'll find out soon!
Oh, nice.
Okay, we insta teleported there.
That's good.
Okay, come on.
Come on!
Let me hit you!
Oh, I He's a girl?
Oh, thank god that hits.
Oh, thank god.
I was so scared that didn't hit.
Okay.
All right.
Get over here.
Okay.
Is he?
No!
Okay.
That's all right.
You're still learning how to walk.
Child.
That's okay.
I know you're still learning.
I don't want to use the cloud step yet.
Because I want to use it for heals.
For emergency heals.
Like, I don't want to waste it yet.
All right.
Freeze!
Oh, thank god.
Thank god I can still hit the toes.
Thank fucking god I can still hit the toes.
Oh, no!
I didn't mean it!
No!
I didn't mean to heal twice!
Okay.
That's so unlucky for me.
Only happens to Toki.
Okay.
Nice.
No!
Fuck!
Okay.
All right.
Nice.
I'm underneath him.
He can't get me when I'm underneath.
Okay.
That's unlucky.
But that's okay.
I'm still underneath him.
Please!
Let me hit one hit!
Oh, thank god.
Okay.
Hit the little toe for maximum damage.
Nice.
He starts damage because the scorpion king will show up.
Whoops!
Wait.
Am I not supposed to kill the scorpion king?
Like...
What?!
Oh, gosh.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Alright.
Alright, buddy.
Okay.
I took damage, but that's okay, I guess.
Let me heal here.
What?
How does that hit me?
Wow!
Oh my god.
Are you sure that's not the pig as well?
Oh god!
Oh!
Whoa!
Time to keep... flying!
Okay, nice.
I'm gonna fucking speed up the arm.
I'm gonna speed up the arm.
Please don't fly.
That's all I ask.
Okay, nice.
It's tiger... oh wait, dragon time!
It's dragon time!
Oh no.
Okay.
That's fine.
Dragon time!
I'm just glad the baby hit.
Like, I'm just so happy I hit the baby.
The baby is like... I swear, the baby is so hard to hit sometimes.
Oh, please.
Please stop moving.
Okay, nice.
Come on.
More damage!
Come on!
Does it...
Do as much as you can, old man!
No.
It's okay, we're fine.
We're so healthy.
Wait, why am I so slow sometimes?
Whoa!
Oh, no.
Heal.
He doesn't know where I am.
Oh, shit!
Okay.
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
I'm so sorry for making fun of you.
Oh, no.
He angry.
Oh, shit!
I hate the way he does that.
Oh, no!
No!
Please, I need to heal.
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
I thought he was gonna fly.
At least he didn't fly.
Come on!
Oh, shit!
Okay.
Okay, we're fine.
We're not fine.
But, like, you know, I'm making do with what I have.
I don't...
Oh, no!
I didn't press two of
an animation!
I
had two more heals, too.
It's not fine.
I had two...
I had two more syphs.
Oh, my God.
We're so close.
Wait, you do that now?
Are you fucking...
Okay.
Like, alright.
That's fine.
Like...
That is...
That is A-okay.
That is A...
That's A-okay.
I'm okay with that.
I'm...
I'm so okay, guys.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe my freeze did that.
I'm so sad.
That... that is actually other bullshit, not gonna lie.
I HATE THIS FUCKING CHICKEN!
I hate this chicken so much.
Holy shit, this chicken.
This goddamn chicken.
This chicken is gonna be the pain of my existence.
Oh my god.
I don't like the animation timing for that too sometimes.
I have to avoid it.
Okay.
Oh shit!
Ow.
Okay, that's fine.
We can... we can mated him from underneath.
It's okay.
We have... we have the backside!
Boom!
Alright.
Now we just gotta...
We just gotta recharge.
Okay.
Just have to recharge here.
Oh shit!
Ow.
It's fine.
We're underneath him!
He doesn't know what to do!
Wait, I'm underneath!
That's fucking right!
Oh, bitch!
Okay.
I'm underneath him again!
He doesn't know!
Haha!
That's right.
Okay.
The backshot.
We got the backshot down to the T.
It's the Blood Moon phase.
Alright, here we go.
It's this phase.
Oh my god, this phase is crazy.
This phase he does whatever the fuck he wants apparently.
I...
Yep.
He does whatever the fuck the chicken wants apparently.
Chicken wants this!
Okay.
God...
He doesn't let me go behind him like the other times.
Like he's...
Chicken has learned.
Like chicken has definitely learned.
Chicken has learned so much.
Chicken, why are you learning?
Wait.
Wait, what?
Did I not heal?
No, I did.
I just lost so much HP for that.
How?
Okay.
Nice.
I got the timing for that.
Okay.
That's good.
That's so good for me.
Okay.
No.
Dragon.
We need you more than ever.
We need you more than ever, old man.
This is your moment to shine.
Yes!
I don't know if I hit that, but I assume I did.
What the world needs you most.
Okay.
Where did he go?
Oh, there you are.
Okay, nice.
Oh, I got the legs.
Nice.
That's good.
Oh, no.
That got me.
No!
Okay.
How did that?
That got me.
Okay.
All right.
Fine.
You can have that.
I don't know how, but you can have it, I guess.
Okay.
What the fuck?
You can have that too.
All right.
Okay.
You can have that as well.
I don't... Oh, my God.
Please.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
Please.
That's it.
No!
Are you fucking kidding me?
It's too...
Are you fucking...
Are you serious?
He's doing that thing again?
Please.
Oh, my God.
I got him.
Holy shit.
I can't believe all of them.
I couldn't kill him because he was in a combo.
These few few years since we met, you have been killed by them I thought.
Why didn't you help?
Were you just watching me?
Miss?
Were you literally just watching me, lady?
Guys, there's no chicken left.
There's no meat left in that fucking guy.
I don't know what you mean by fried chicken.
It's literally just bone.
What about your husband?
I thought we were trying to find your husband.
Your dead husband.
Oh!
Well, let's mix my fight boss up.
Just to classify it easier.
That's the husband?
How the fuck did he turn into that?
She married a chicken?
Oh, it's her adopted brother.
Oh!
Bro, that's messed up, lady.
That's your fucking not real brother.
But, like, you still have, like, family ties.
There was no husband?
Did everybody lie to me?
Oh, I finished it.
Okay.
I can't believe it.
Can't believe it.
Everybody's lying.
They all lied to me.
Does no one have integrity anymore?
Everybody lies to me and I can't talk.
I can't even defend myself.
It's so messed up.
Oh, hey, there's so many Buddha statues here.
Is there anything here?
Is there a secret?
All right, up we go.
I don't even remember how...
That world was so long.
I don't even remember what I was doing before.
I felt like I was trapped in this area for so long.
All right, nice.
Oh, I got a pill.
Yeah, that was a side quest.
I've been in this side quest for so long, I actually don't know what to do anymore.
I don't know what to do in the main storyline.
All right.
That it?
How do I get out of here?
Oh, I guess we go up here.
Oh, can I go back in?
Oh, I can.
I already finished it though.
I already finished the area there.
All right.
Now, I guess...
The talisman quest?
I had another quest?
Guys, I'm so...
I don't know.
That side quest was like...
It felt like 20 years, guys.
I'm just like, I had another one?
I had another side quest?
All right.
Oh, hey, item.
What's this?
Oh, a drink.
All right.
How did I get here?
Like what was this where?
I'm trying to retrace my steps to figure out how I got here in general.
I don't remember how I got to this area.
Oh, pull the mushrooms?
Oh, is there a mushroom boss?
Oh, okay, I'll pull the mushroom.
All right.
Guess what?
Yeah,
this is why I don't pull the mushroom, because I know there's gonna be a boss.
This is exactly why I don't pull it.
Not like boss, but because I know one of them is a fucking...
Not boss, but just like... Oh, there you go.
Oh, it's a mushroom boss woman.
Because I know this guy was gonna show up.
Like a fucker.
There you go.
I'm just gonna use everything.
I can't be bothered.
He won't have a chance to get up at this rate.
You know what?
I'm bringing him too.
That fucking rap brought him over.
That's right.
You're not gonna be able to play the game.
Oh my god, he hits so hard.
Holy shit.
What the fuck?
Okay, I guess I don't play the...
Wait, he heals?
Okay.
How did he heal?
How does he... What?
I don't understand.
How is he healing?
Oh, he steals my... He has life steal!
Okay, this is bullshit.
This is actually bullshit.
Oh my god, this guy has life steal.
I don't even wanna fight him anymore.
This is actually bullshit.
I used all that power up and it didn't matter because he had life steal!
Yeah, that's right.
We're gonna steal now.
He still stole my health!
I was invisible!
I was actually invisible and he still stole my health!
That's actually crazy!
Wait a minute, that's actually illegal!
Oh my god, just don't get hit.
Guys, I went through this entire game about learning how to use that staff spin thing.
Guys, I don't know.
Oh my god, I don't know.
That's actually crazy that he has that though.
Oh wait, this... No!
No, I forgot!
He can steal my life with this guy.
This is not fair.
Oh no!
Okay.
Oh come on!
No!
Don't you...
Don't you fucking dare!
Oh my god, bro.
This guy...
He's actually gonna be the bane of my existence with this stupid life steal.
Oh my god!
This boss took 20 years logging!
Jesus.
Alright.
Okay, we did it.
Where did I come from?
Oh my god.
Wait.
Where did I...
Which...
Where did I come from?
Oh, here.
Here.
I came from over there.
Okay.
Oh, I missed the soul?
Did I actually?
Do we need that guy's soul?
Alright.
We're gonna take this and then we're gonna...
We're gonna do the quest... I'm gonna do instant transmission.
I don't know how far I am anymore.
I can life steal with her?
Yeah, but big baby!
Big baby has never failed me.
Okay.
We go this way.
Where do we go?
She'll never get up to stop me.
I'm so quick.
Content.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright.
Where do we go?
Oh, hey.
Brew.
Upgrade?
Ooh.
35.
Grants a considerable amount of chi?
Yeah, but that's not mana.
I like the mana.
What's this?
Okay.
We don't need that.
Up those stairs?
Behind the trees.
Okay.
Stairs.
I was like, where's the stairs?
Okay.
Up those stairs.
I can make a new staff?
Okay.
Nice.
Craft weapon.
No, I can't.
Fucking liars.
Oh, wait.
No, I can.
I can.
Never mind.
JK.
I never called you a liar.
I'm only joking, guys.
Modern increases the damage by all Pillar Stance moves.
A long can be summoned to execute thunder at the enemy at Pillar Stance.
A cost of...
I was just joking.
I never said that.
I'll never call you guys liars.
Yeah?
Oh, there's the shrine.
There it is.
Yay!
I did it.
Oh, he looks mean.
What the fuck?
How do you eat?
Where's your mouth?
I can't.
You only have one hole?
Or two holes?
Like, where's your map?
I'm just concerned.
Like, I don't understand.
Wait, that's it?
All hands!
Underneath that!
Underneath the chest!
Oh, he's a bird!
Which one?
There's so many girls.
Wait, no!
That's fucked!
I just met her too!
Like...
Bro!
Why did you assume she was my girlfriend?
I literally just met her!
Not every lady I talk to is my girlfriend, bro.
Oh, that's fucked.
Okay.
Let's grab the item.
Oh, nice.
Maximum stamina.
We need that.
Alright, guys.
Where do we go?
Do we go up?
Oh, now it's personal.
They're always watching.
Bro, just cause I had a dream about her, it doesn't mean like we're dating or anything.
Oh, there's nowhere to go here.
Nice.
Wait, that air...
What the fuck?
What the fuck were they?
Okay, that was creepy.
Okay, that's creepy.
Oh my god, these...
They're like the twins from that...
Stanley Kubrick, The Shining.
We go up here?
Equip the Nina.
This...
Oh.
Oh, here.
Homes in on an attacks highly affected against...
Oh, this one.
Okay.
We go here?
Is this the final boss here?
Oh, no.
It's an item.
Play with us, Doki.
Oh, nice.
A side entrance from the shrine?
Yeah, but there was another...
Um, area that I didn't go.
Uh, when I got the...
Where was it?
It's like here?
How did I get here?
Oh, there he is.
Guys, I think that's the boss.
Guys, I think...
Guys, does this look like the boss?
I remember there was like an area that I forgot.
There was an area that I didn't go to.
Sorry, it took me a while to get this to hit.
Oh, it was in the optional area.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There was a...
I remember now.
There was an area in the optional area.
Guys, do you think like...
Do you think...
Do you think they're friendly?
Hahaha.
No, there was an area I didn't explore.
Because I was like confused.
I was like...
Somewhere here.
Let's see.
It was like...
Here and then turn left, I think.
I'm pretty sure.
I'm pretty sure I didn't explore that, right?
I don't remember.
There, there, this way, this way.
I didn't go left.
Wait, no, not this way.
Sorry.
This way.
I didn't go left.
Yeah, I didn't go left here.
I did.
I am so fucking stupid.
This is where I came from.
Oh my god.
That's literally where I went.
Okay.
I'm so fucking okay.
Let's go back.
Okay.
I did.
I went there.
Okay.
But I had to go this way, guys.
No.
I had to go this back because I need to kill the last tiger.
I need to kill the last tiger and put him out of his misery.
Okay.
We got to put the tiger out of their misery, guys.
Go.
When do I use the needle, chat?
When do I...?
Like, when do I use it?
In the very beginning or...?
Okay.
Let's get the last one.
On phase two.
Okay.
When chat spams needle.
All right.
On phase two.
Okay.
I'm going to heal up and then get ready for the opening.
You know
what, I'm gonna go upgrade my... I have a lot of like mine core shit, so I'm gonna upgrade that.
I need to go... I need to upgrade my stuff.
Alright, do you have anything for me?
Who mentioned that I'm not gonna use?
Oh, Celestia.
Okay, how much?
Oh, I have eight.
Alright, guys, what do we upgrade, guys?
Do we get stamina recover- I feel like I'm gonna get one- actually, I'm gonna get one stamina recovery.
Just cause like, I feel like we need that.
Alright, what do we put it in?
HP?
Alright.
HP.
Stamina and HP.
Okay, I'll do...
a little more stamina.
And then- oh, I actually can't do HP.
Oh, no.
Do I have enough?
Oh, nice.
Hey.
Oh, I do!
I do!
Okay.
I can...
Can I do mana too?
Yeah!
I can just have enough for HP and mana.
Nice.
Yeah, I'm gonna put it on mana as well.
Okay, plus 15.
And then...
Mana.
Alright, we got our upgrades.
Nice.
Okay, what do we need to do?
Uh...
Alright.
Upgrade core time!
I need the fragrant vine.
Do you have that, sir?
Oh, is that it?
Yeah!
You do!
I can buy it!
Okay.
Uh...
Yeah.
Okay.
I have so much money.
Yay!
Each sip using increases damage reduction.
Nice.
How about drinks?
Ten-year-old coconut wine?
Okay, obviously, like, I'm not using that.
Alright.
Let's talk to you.
Do you have anything for me?
Sir?
Sure.
Yay!
More stuff I'm not gonna use!
Buy the worm and upgrade it?
Okay.
Uh...
Which one was it?
Is this this guy?
Okay.
?
Nice.
Do I have... Am I...
This is what I'm drinking?
Oh, this is what I'm drinking!
Oh!
I understand now!
What?
Okay, so I'll buy all of them.
Okay, I'll buy all of them for now.
Because I have the money anyway.
Yeah, I have way too much!
I have too much!
Okay!
Wait.
Immortal blessing.
Oh, it recovers you to a certain amount of health or... No, we don't need those.
Alright.
Wait, do I have a different... Am I not using that?
Am I on a burn resistance?
And...
Why the fuck am I using burn resistance?
Sorry.
I should be using this.
I'm just like, what the fuck?
The
fuck was I using burn resistance?
I'm so...
I'm just like, what?
That's such a good question.
I don't even know.
I don't even know why.
Might recovery rate.
Damage reduction and might recovery.
Okay.
If it heals, it heals.
I'm just like, when the fuck did that happen?
And mushroom cap and release spores.
Spores that can return and recover health.
Okay guys, which is better?
We finally leave Big Baby?
Or do we go with sport Fungi Woman?
Are we really gonna ditch Big Baby after everything he's done for us?
Of course not.
We respect Big Baby.
Can't believe you guys would suggest a thing.
I can't believe it, guys.
Can't believe you guys would wanna ditch Big Baby.
How could you?
After everything Big Baby did for us.
How fucking could you?
Respect.
Baby has carried us this far.
And you wanna leave Big Baby now?
Okay.
This is here, right?
Where was I?
Oh, Court of Illumination.
Alright,
here we go.
This is it.
Fungi has lifesteal.
But Fungi has never been with us since the beginning.
It's called Honor Code.
It's called the Bro Code, guys.
Big Baby has been there from the very beginning.
How many polygons is this?
You don't understand.
The Is that the master?
Is that him?
Is that the tiger-hater?
He's gonna kill her!
Oh!
It's the relic!
He's taking the relic back!
No way!
No!
What the fuck is going on?
Oh my god!
He was a bug!
I fucking knew it!
Fucking knew it!
That's why he hated tigers!
The Hundred-Eyed Taoist Master.
So that's why he was turning all of them into bugs!
That's his way of impregnating.
No!
They're children!
What the fuck?
Oh shit!
Sorry.
I should help.
I'm so sorry.
I should help you.
Watch the children fight.
I'm just like...
Wait, I should be helping.
I'm sorry.
I was...
No!
They just have a weapon!
Okay, that's not it.
I'm not mean to kill multiple monkeys.
I didn't mean...
Okay, now we're in trouble.
We have the mother monkeys and okay.
Alright, I wasted my mana, but that's okay.
That's okay.
Alright, spotters, go!
Okay, but what happens if like...
What happens if I die on this run?
Do I not have the spotters anymore?
No!
I didn't want to summon...
Wait, where are the other spotters?
What happened to them?
Did they die?
Bing!
Like, the fight's not over.
Why did they leave?
I wasn't even part of this fight.
I don't understand why they left.
We weren't even originally part of this fight.
So like, there's no reason...
Why did they leave?
Like I wasn't... Okay, this does not make sense.
Why did they go home?
Why did they leave?
Wait, they fell.
You had it Adam!
This was their fight!
Like, that's the thing!
This was literally their fight!
I was just like a bystanding.
Oh shit!
I need to hydrate.
Okay.
Like literally not even part of the scenario.
Not even part of this.
Okay, I don't know his pattern so like I'm a little bit...
Oh my god!
Holy shit, okay!
Can he hydrate?
To be fair, he has your stuff.
Yeah, but like...
They should be mad at...
Mad at him, not me!
Like I said, like I literally just showed up!
Like they did this stuff with their mom, not me!
This was like a fight related to their mom!
Oh shit, okay.
I should hydrate though.
Hydrate time!
Oh shit!
Oh my god!
Oh, that's bad!
This is bad!
Okay, nice!
Okay, not as bad as I thought.
Alright, nice!
I'm just gonna hydrate again.
Just in case.
Okay!
Time to leave!
Whoa!
What is he doing?
I don't know what this is!
Oh!
Is this this?
Is that what it does?
The needle.
Okay.
Nice.
I remembered.
I remembered you guys saying you see a lot of balls, just needle.
I read.
What the fuck?
What?
What is he doing?
What are you doing?
I'm so sad.
I'm...
Okay, goodbye.
Okay.
I'm...
Hydrate.
Just gotta hydrate, I guess.
What else would I do but hydrate?
Okay.
Oh, shit!
Oh, hydrate!
Hydrate!
Oh!
Whoa!
Okay, nice.
I did it.
I didn't die.
That's good.
Jesus Christ.
Oh, my God.
He does so much.
Oh, God.
Okay.
Oh, shit!
Okay, that's fine.
It's fine.
Oh, my God, that's not final flight.
Oh, he does this thing and I don't know what it does, but he does it and it scares me..
Did I do any damage to him?
I can't tell!
Okay...
What the fuck was-
Boom!
Okay.
I'm just gonna do one less hydrate for now, before I hit him on his legs.
Oh yeah!
No, no, no, no, no, no!
No!
Yeah.
I swear to god!
Now that he grabbed me!
I can never die!
Holy shit, he's so fucking light!
Oh no.
Oh god, grab him!
Granny!
Wait, she absorbed him?
He absorbed her?
Is she dying?
She's like, 500 years old.
It's her time.
Cold, she is.
Now they come back!
Yeah!
That's your child.
Remember your life support- your child support, Pigsy.
Where did he come from?
She's like, my pig's a dad.
My dad's a- my dad's a pig.
She's like, I'm not a pig.
Don't be a dead.
Go to her A!
Don't be a dead beat!
Or I'll skin you alive!
You fuck!
Bro...
After all those rounds?!
Damn.
Is that her?
The spider?
No, this is... No, this is based off of...
No, it's based off of the Moon Festival, right?
Yeah, the Moon Goddess.
Yeah, I saw the moon and I was like, oh, the rabbit ears.
That's her.
You'll never find them.
I love the animation.
But I don't know what...
Oh!
He got cursed because he hit on her.
God damn it, Pigsy.
God damn it.
Bro.
Yeah.
Bro, did she?
Bro!
Did she?
Okay.
That was like the catfish.
It's not so bad.
The spider and the pig.
Okay.
Oh, fuck you.
Holy shit.
Oh.
He spent so many years together.
Then he chose the...
Bro!
He left her.
For the bros.
That's right.
Bros before...
No, I'm just joking.
No.
That's sad for her.
That's for my own...
He chose the monkey.
No.
For the bros.
Yeah, I remember they killed all the sisters.
Yeah.
I remember.
It's like...
Yeah,
it's funny.
Like, yeah, they killed all of their sisters.
People always make, like, adaptations where they get...
The spiders get revenge on them for that.
You're expecting you to cry, but you laugh.
That's so fucked up.
Zafirman, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I did not realize because, like, our whole thing today on this stream was like, bro, guys.
Bros before hoes, guys.
And he literally...
He literally bros before hoder.
Friendship ended with birds and bees.
And aggi, he's only pigs and spiders now.
Well, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you, bro.
I can't believe it, bro.
You had so many children.
Wait, then they're all his.
Qingsi bu zhan. ,.
From the epic leader of Tianhe, from the official leader of Tianpeng, to the Zhugeli to Qujing's The majority of them were his.
Bro, they were banging for a long time.
Who's the chicken?
Oh, the chicken!
That's the guy we killed.
Oh, those guys.
The court, from the high court.
Alright.
Did I miss anything?
I love the artwork they do for this too.
Oh, that's the centipede, the hundred eyes.
All my homies hate the celestial court, true.
Alright.
Well, he chose us.
So who's the real winner?
Not her.
Look, he can find many spider ladies, but he can only find one.
One group of bros.
No!
Toki, please!
Okay, next chapter.
Spiders have a lot of fucking kids!
Okay, but a group of bros?
That's forever.
Alright, next chapter.
Chapter five.
Golden child, crimson blood.
What happened?
Did I miss the spider?
No!
Fuck, oops.
Nice work, Toki.
The last boss, second phase.
I learned the hard way.
Have fun, next chapter.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm just gonna look at the intro, and then we'll see how I feel here.
What the fuck?
Is this zombie land?
What is this?
What are they?
Hey.
Woods of ember.
Oh, shit.
Wait, they're not dead?
Wait, they are zombies then.
Oh, shit.
Wait, is that...
Is he gonna be like that forever?
Like...
Oh, shit!
Is Pixie gonna be like that forever now?
Okay, give me a sec, Pixie.
I'm heading over.
My hands were on the wrong...
Okay, now that makes sense.
I had my hands... I moved my hands to the right.
Is that in combat mode now?
Oh, ow.
Okay.
They're dead, they're dead.
Oh, they're not dead.
Oh, there's a lot more.
Okay, never mind.
I was like, what are you doing?
It's over.
Oh my god!
You don't even do any damage!
You barely...
You better off as a smaller pig.
Not gonna lie.
Okay, I feel like he does more damage when he's in this small form.
The jump was cool though.
And here comes Pixie with the steel chair!
Oh, you did like 0.1 damage.
Whoa!
It is zombies!
They reanimate!
Or combine?
Yoki, he literally lost his wife.
Please let him go.
Yoki, please.
He lost his wife.
Alright.
Where do I...
Do I go straight?
I assume I go straight.
I don't need a shrine.
Alright, open up.
Knock, knock!
Alright.
Whoa!
What is that?
What the fuck is that?
What are you?
Oh, shit!
Guys, please.
One at a time, guys.
One at a...
Okay, guys.
We do it in an order, everybody.
This has to be an order.
A nice, fashionable order.
Okay, what is this?
Oh, I forgot like they...
Oh, here you go.
Nice.
Everyone take a number.
Alright.
I remember somebody said to go back to a chapter for a secret boss.
Is that true or were you guys fucking with me?
I don't know if that was true or not.
Okay.
I'm just trying to see if there's...
90%?
That shit's nothing.
Should I craft this?
Just to see if there's like stuff over there?
Not yet?
I just complete the...
I need to complete a secret zone in chapter 5 first.
Okay.
Alright.
Then we're gonna call it here.
We're gonna call it here.
I'll craft some armor first too.
Might as well so I don't forget to do that later.
So I should craft this so future Doki doesn't forget.
Alright.
Oh, nice.
Whoa.
Okay.
Cause I know future Doki's definitely gonna forget.
Alright.
So then we'll put this on.
Nice.
Poison resistance on the land of fire.
That's counterintuitive.
But like, welcome to life, baby.
Alright!
We're gonna call it here.
We made a lot of progress.
I mean, 5 hours to finish this chapter.
So, yeah.
That's good enough for me.
Not gonna lie.
Alright, let me...
Alright.
Oh!
That was really fun!
I had a great time.
And it has been really, really, really It's been a really fun time.
Just playing the next...going back to Wukong.
And completing the chapter finally!
Completing!
Completing the bug chapter.
We're so close to finishing the game.
We're so close.
I think we have two more chapters left to go.
So, how long is chapter 5 anyway?
How long is chapter 5, guys?
I'd stream longer, but this week is super packed with a lot of responsibility.
With a lot of stuff going on.
So I guess...
I would love to...
Oh my gosh.
I would love to play a lot more, but I want to make sure I don't go overboard and that I don't lose my voice.
So that's why I have to make sure I don't overdo it today.
But yeah!
Thank you everybody for coming!
I hope you guys had a great time watching.
I might put my schedule out today.
The sponsor stuff hasn't been fully confirmed yet.
So I'm just going to put sponsor special stream on that day.
And if it doesn't get confirmed, then that's going to be a rest day.
But yes!
A lot of stuff going on behind the scenes.
A lot of stuff going on this week.
But I hope you guys had a great time watching.
I always love streaming for you guys.
As always everybody, stay hydrated, posture check, get up and move around to get that blood flowing!
And if you stayed up for me, head to bed!
Because you deserve it!
I'll see you guys next time everybody!
Bye-bye guys!
Bye-bye!